As-salamu alaykum guys. Before we start
today's session, this is part of a
greater project called the Sapience
Academy. This is one of the greatest
academies in the world when it comes to
interdisciplinary studies and
intellectually defending Islam. I would
argue it's the best. It's the best in
the world when we talk about things like
feminism, liberalism, atheism. Yes, if
you want to defend Islam and have
information like the ones that you're
going to see today, click the link below
and go through the courses that we've
got in the Sapience Academy. As-salamu
alaykum.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh and welcome to another session
where we're going to be talking about
something very, very important, which is
feminism.
And actually, we're going to be speaking
about pseudo-Islamic feminism.
Or
what Ali has coined now, I think is I
have to give him credit for this.
The nifaqi feminism, or which we're
going to come to this, which is the
strand of feminism which attempts to
harmonize between Islam
and feminism, tries to reconcile between
those two things. Although, as we said,
that's a theologically and
intellectually bankrupt and impossible
exercise. So, we're going to be speaking
about that, but before we do speak about
that, we're going to be speaking about
feminism just as a recap and an
overview. Obviously, we've done lots of
sessions in before as part of the London
area I've spoke about first wave and
second wave feminism, etc.
And I've written a book on feminism
called fifth wave feminism where I'm
responding to intersectional feminist
approaches, which is like third wave and
beyond.
But this is going to be a quick
overview, but with some very important
information, I think.
The first thing I think that we need to
say is this.
Now, if you go to a lot of the masajid,
if you go to a lot of the
students of knowledge kind of circles,
right? If you go to a lot of the
academic centers of Islamic studies, if
you go to the aqidah studies that they
study, right?
Is ancient and outdated a lot of it.
Because what they'll say is, let's talk
about the Mu'tazila, for example.
The rationalists, the Mu'tazila. Let's
talk about khalq al-Qur'an.
Because Imam Ahmad was so opposed to
khalq al-Qur'an that he was put into
prison for such and such a thing. He was
Imam Ahmad was put into prison because
the people believed in khalq al-Qur'an
and he had no he said a creation of the
Qur'an, he said no, the Qur'an is not
created and he was tortured for that.
So, we have to go through that.
Let's talk about the Khawarij.
Although that does have some level of
continuity with some of the things and
the movements today. Let's talk about
the early Shi'a. Let's talk about this
and that.
Although all of these things have their
place.
I want to submit to the people watching
at home today
that frankly, if you go to the average
Muslim and you tell them and you ask
them what is the difference what are the
key differences between an Ash'ari and a
Maturidi? I should forget about the
average Muslim. I assure you the
students of knowledge don't even know
the differences. A student of knowledge
if I ask a student of knowledge give me
three differences between the Ash'ari
school and the Maturidi school. He will
not be able to outline three
differences. I promise you. If you go to
a layperson and tell them what's the
difference between the Athari and
Ash'ari aqidah. You might be able to
squeeze from some of them or some of
them believe that you know the Allah is
above the throne and the other ones
don't believe in that.
Maybe. But if you go to any layperson
not just in the West
but in Latin America,
in Asia, in the Middle East
and you ask them about the feminist
movement.
Every single I'm not going to say every
single one of them but
great number of people especially in the
West
probably a majority of people know what
feminism is
and they have been affected by it.
Likewise with liberalism.
But somehow
the aqidah syllabi have not been
adjusted to refute these two most
threatening
aqidah aspects. Because look, these are
claims to akhlaqiyat, to ethics.
They have a separate ethical system.
Feminism and liberalism has a separate
ethical system and they affect the iman
of the Muslim people. So, this is aqidah
studies.
Yet the aqidah syllabi have not been
adapted and updated to reflect how to
respond to the feminist movement or to
feminist [snorts] claims or feminist
attacks against Islam. Although we have
found
that feminism
has actually constitutes for Muslim
people, feminism and liberalism, those
two ideologies,
the basis of a lot of the doubts that
they have about Islam.
For example, we have in Sapience, this
institute here, we have the Lighthouse
mentoring service. And I asked Luqman
Yusuf Pond as who's doing great work
there
to tell me what are the five he's
tabulated everything. I said what are
the five most
things that people have shubuhat about,
like doubts, destructive doubts about.
And three out of the five were related
somehow to feministic ideas.
Things about Islam which are not
incommensurate with feminism. People
have doubts about that.
And what we've found is that in in
Islamic history or in the recent times,
the mashayikh and the ulama and all
these, they have an approach which is
trying to do some kind of a
hermeneutical gymnastics, trying to get
the verse to fit with like popular
conceptions. And that's a weak and
backfooted and impossible approach. And
in fact, it probably leads to more
apostasy and shakk and doubt and rayb
than anything else. The correct approach
is a confrontational approach to those
elements of aqidah
that oppose Islam in a direct way. In
the same way as Imam Ahmad opposed the
Mu'tazila. If you I bid to you and I
submit to you that if he was alive
today, he would be opposing these.
If al-Ghazali was alive today, he would
be opposing these.
If Ibn Taymiyyah was alive today, he
would be he would the first thing he'd
be speaking about is not khalq
al-Qur'an.
He'd be speaking about the most
destructive elements of
the aqidah of the Muslims which is
feminism and liberalism because of the
global hegemonic power which has allowed
those two ideologies to flourish for
economic reasons which we'll come to.
So, let me ask a question to start us
all up.
What is the definition of feminism?
Who knows what the definition of
feminism is?
You know no one knows it.
Yeah.
What's the definition of feminism?
You guys talk about feminism all the
time. What's the definition of it? Go
ahead.
That women are equal to men in every
way.
That's not really a correct that's not
correct, okay? The correct definition
is, yeah?
Equal rights for men and women. Yeah, so
that it's more of a prescriptive
statement.
It's they want there to be equal rights.
So, equality was correct. That part of
it was correct. They want there to be
equal rights for men and women socially,
economically and politically. That's the
most basic definition like Britannica
Encyclopedia uses that definition, etc.
However,
the fact of the matter is that in
academia,
feminism
is not just one strand. You have, for
example,
liberal feminism, okay?
You have what is referred to as
materialist feminism. Now, materialist
feminism is like Marxist feminism.
Either Marxist or socialist and both of
them are on the same spectrum, yeah?
And you have radical feminism. These are
the three main in in the
academic literature, the three main
types of feminism, okay?
Which have been represented. Obviously,
there's different waves which we can go
through quickly now.
But you should be aware
that each of those kinds of feminists
would have a kind of different
definition to the other one as to what
feminism is.
So, if you ask a Marxist feminist,
you'll have a slightly different
definition of what feminism is to a
liberal feminist. A liberal feminist
will have a slightly different
definition as to what a materialist
feminist and so on and so forth.
But one thing that unites all of these
feminists together
is an idea of the patriarchy.
Okay.
Now, what is this patriarchy? Explain to
me what the someone tell me what the
patriarchy is.
Is it that society is run by
like the male figure,
whether it's the family, government,
institutions,
all down to the micro level. Yeah, sure.
That's not bad.
>> [laughter]
>> That's fine. It's run by it's run by
men, right?
Most
I mean here's here's the thing. With
patriarchy, there's no fixed definition.
Once again, different thinkers have
different ideas. But I'll give you one
definition, okay?
Which I think captures a lot of what
patriarchy is about.
Sylvia Walby
defines patriarchy as a system of social
structures and practices in which men
dominate, oppress and exploit women.
It's not just that
it's not just that they have power over
them. They dominate over them.
They oppress them and they exploit them.
Okay?
Now,
why is it that they think that men are
dominating, oppressing and exploiting
women?
And they think that's happened
throughout history and they think that's
also happening now. Why do you think
they think that?
Say that again. Why do you think that
feminist theorists, whether they are
radical feminist, liberal feminist or
materialist feminist, why do you think
that those particular feminist theorists
believe that historically men have been
dominating, oppressing
women? Why is that?
How? Because that that that that has
that that has happened.
But it depends how they define it. So,
men men are the ones who've been
dominating certain work fields,
but they've misconstrued it to make it
seem as if
them dominating those areas means that
they are treated unequally. So, that's
that's number one. That's good. I
actually don't I don't think that's bad,
but let me
let me get couple of other answers and
then I'm going to give you a couple of
also Christianity as well played a role
as well. Sure. The discussion of does a
woman have a soul and this that.
Two brief reasons might be number one,
men have the highest paying jobs and so
on and so forth. And secondly, men are
usually the leaders of the nuclear
family, the traditional nuclear family.
So, there's some examples of that. So,
>> Men are usually the leaders of the
nuclear family, the traditional nuclear
>> beautiful. So there's some examples of
that. So that's a good point that some
of them say that the evidence of a
patriarchy is that men have been allowed
into certain fields than women have not
been allowed to historically, right?
For example, politics. There's been more
male leaders in history in every
civilization than women. Et cetera, et
cetera. They'll give many different
examples of that.
Now, I'm just going to get straight into
this, okay? Um
and refute this, okay? Because
attention spans now are very low. So I
need to get straight into the thick of
it.
The refutation of patriarchy is as
follows, okay?
And I want you to write this somewhere
down, okay?
Refutation number one.
Patriarchy assumes
in many cases
that just the fact that men have power
over women is an evidence of oppression.
Mhm. Let me say that again.
Patriarchy assumes
just the fact that men have power over
women
is evidence of what? Oppression.
Where did they get this understanding
from?
You could argue, and this is what I
think they got it from, especially the
radical and materialist strands
but also the liberal strands.
They probably got it from critical
theorists.
Now, critical theory
I don't want to give you too much
information, all right? But critical
theory started with something called the
Frankfurt School.
Okay.
And you had someone called Adorno
and Horkheimer, Max Horkheimer, and
others
who started this school
the Frankfurt School and they
essentially said
that where there is a power
relationship, that's evidence of
oppression.
Okay?
They actually followed up from Marx,
Karl Marx. If you remember when we were
talking about uh Marxism in the Londoner
we said that Marx essentially had this
idea that the upper class are exploiting
the
lower classes or the working classes.
The bourgeoisie is oppressing the
proletariat. Yeah, this is the
technical terms.
They're they're doing that by being in
that hierarchy. So hierarchy is
inherently what? Oppressive.
That is the hidden assumption
of many of the patriarchy theorists.
That hierarchy is what?
Is oppression. Now, what's the what's
the question that we want to ask? What's
the evidence for that? No.
Even the Quran mentions, and this is to
bring Islam into it
that we have put some of you above
others so that some of you can employ
others.
So from the Islamic perspective
hierarchy does not mean
oppression. In fact, there's a clear
verse. That's probably one of the
clearest verse in the Quran that shows
you hierarchy cannot mean because Allah
is allowing the hierarchy. Allah is
saying here he is allowing the hierarchy
to happen.
Some people have more money than others.
Some people have more knowledge than
others. Some people have more whatever
than others.
Allah is allowing that as an imtihan, as
a as a test for the people.
But obviously that's from our spiritual
confessional perspective. We're going
back now.
If they are saying that a hierarchy
means oppression, they need to provide
what?
They need to provide evidence for that
because they don't have any evidence. So
the first question that you would ask
someone who believes in patriarchy
theory is what?
Do you believe, first question, put this
question down somewhere, do you believe
that just the fact that men have had
power, if we assume that they have, and
this is a questionable supposition,
right?
Do you believe that the fact that men
have power over women is evidence of
oppression? If they say yes then you ask
them what?
Bring your evidence for that. And you'll
see them scramble because no one has
been able to bring evidence for that.
What's the question again? Do you
Do you believe power relationships
between men and women, where men
dominate women through power indicates
oppression from one party to the other,
yeah?
If they say yes
we do believe that. Of course it does
mean that. So what's the evidence for
that? Bring
your evidence. You are now proposing
that just by the fact that there's a
power hierarchy, huh?
That there's oppression. You haven't
provided any evidence for that, have
you?
The second So that's refutation number
one.
Refutation number one is that the
premise is wrong that power equals
oppression. That's refutation number
one. Any questions on refutation number
>> Well, what what what's the refutation
though?
>> So we're we're refuting what?
What are we refuting here? Yeah, but
what's the example you're giving?
No, no. What what's the the main thing
we're refuting? That the power relation
Yeah. So we're refuting the
I'm going to call it patriarchy theory,
okay? Which is I would say if if there
was one pillar of feminism, you know how
Islam has five pillars?
>> Yeah. There was one pillar of feminism,
it would be patriarchy. If you can get
that, you can break feminism.
Yeah? You can break the whole ideology.
So I'm giving you refutations for how to
break patriarchy because if you can get
break that one, you break everything.
The first thing we said patriarchy
assumes that men dominate women and that
equals what?
Oppression. We said that they probably
got this from critical theorists. Like
who? What school? What's it called?
The Frankfurt School. Yes?
And then you can research that in your
own time.
And some of them go for the
post-modernist school. I'm not going to
go That's a bit too deep for now. Which
assumes that power equals what?
Oppression.
>> Oppression, right? Okay, excellent. If
power equals oppression
what's the evidence for that?
That's We only have one question cuz
you're making a claim, right? That the
men have had power over women and that
means that they've oppressed them. Okay,
what's the evidence for that? You see?
The second refutation.
The second refutation
which I thought about when I was in the
shower. Usually my best ideas come
there, yeah?
>> [laughter]
>> Is
Okay.
Why do they say men have power over
women? Because they're stronger than
them, because they're in certain
industries that they're not in. They
give a variety of different examples.
Let me ask you guys a question.
Is there a power relationship between a
mother and a child?
Yeah. Yes, there is. Who's more
powerful, the mother or the child? The
Mother. Is that the case
cross-civilizationally? Yes.
>> Yes. Is that the case historically? Yes.
Yes.
So you could say throughout history
mothers have had power over children,
right? Yeah. Even when they become
adults, they have power still over them.
They have influence, right?
So why is there not a word to describe
this phenomenon just like there's a word
like patriarchy? Yeah.
Since you are against all types of power
hierarchies, then why are you allowing
mothers to have power over children? Or
is it only when men have power that you
have a problem? But when women have
power, you have no problem. And that's
interesting cuz they can come and say,
yeah, but
mothers tend to love their children and
they won't they won't oppress them. But
we know through our
NSPCC that women are the ones that more
likely to abuse their children.
>> That's a good point. But the point I'm
making is that they're they're going
further than that. They're saying any
power hierarchy means what? Oppression.
Didn't they say that?
>> Yes. So if they say any power hierarchy
equals oppression, if a mother has a
power hierarchy, therefore a mother is
doing what? Oppression.
Now, I'll be honest with you because I
have to be for the sake of honesty, some
of them will admit that.
Now, I was in the gender studies
department for postgraduate for one
year. People don't know When I wrote my
book actually, I I spent a whole year
doing gender studies with the
transgender people and these guys. I was
there for a year studying.
And in fact, when I did the book, each
of those little essays that I did were
essays that I handed in, they reviewed
it, and then I made it into a little
book. And all of them got hamdulillah
excellent distinction marks, you know,
as you would expect.
But nevertheless
I actually brought this up in a seminar
in a way and they did a lot of them bit
the bullet with it.
And I was surprised to see that they bit
the bullet. They said, yes, I agree.
And the ones who would bite the bullet
with it are the intersectionalist
feminists.
Third wave feminists, they Some of them
will bite the bullet.
They say, yes, mothers have been
oppressing children. And that's why
there should be an equality even with
that. And you'll find some of that being
now echoed by the way in Netflix series
and stuff.
And there should be a whole program done
on Netflix series and how Netflix
influences through third wave feminism
these ideas.
Like for example, they'll make the child
be the one who has to make the decision
and the the parent is the one who has to
listen, and there's an equality between
child and parent. They're they're
clearly putting that forward.
So some feminists will bite the bullet
on that. But my criticism is, why is
there no word for this? Okay? There's a
word for patriarchy, but there's no word
for the relationship between mother and
what?
Child. Yes. Isn't the argument
Yeah, but there's dependency there as
well because if if the vessel of the man
is stronger than the vessel of the woman
then there's clearly dependency from one
another. And it doesn't matter if
there's dependency or not biologically.
For them, they only care that these
particular ones only care if there's
power. It doesn't matter how the power
got there.
If there's power, then it's oppressive.
You see? So if they're saying it doesn't
matter how the power got there, whether
it's biologically justified or whatever,
they don't care about any of that. The
question is if there's power, they say
power is evidence of oppression, okay?
So I'm saying if power is evidence of
oppression, the mothers have been
oppressive for the last 5,000 years of
civilization, human civilization, and
beyond actually, before civilization.
You see? The third refutation. Do you
understand this refutation? Okay. The
third refutation of patriarchy.
The third refutation is actually one I
found from a feminist.
Which her name was Catherine Hakim,
okay?
And it's mentioned in the slides. You
can look at the slides in your own time.
But she had something and I was reading
her
papers and stuff.
And she's a self-described feminist. I
mean, don't let the surname uh
uh fool you. She's not a Muslim or
anything like that. Maybe she had a
maybe Muslim father, but she's nothing
to do with Islam.
She's a proper feminist.
She had something called preference
theory.
A very interesting thing.
And now remember, she's coming from a
liberal individualistic perspective. She
says the following.
She says
She first of all, she done a study in I
think it was Australia in the beginning
and then she did in other places
where she asked women what they want to
do.
What would they prefer to do?
So, women were divided into three
types.
Some of them said what?
Some of them said we'd rather be
stay-at-home mothers.
Some of them said, "No, we want to be
career-orientated."
And the vast majority wanted to do a bit
of both, part-time work and rearing the
children. This is Western women, white
women, right?
And then she said that the the
patriarchy assumes that for human
history
or for that that it assumes that the
reason why women are in not in the
workplaces they want to be in is because
they've been stopped but the fact is
they've preferred it.
Do you understand this point?
The the assumption is women
have wanted to go into the military,
have wanted to be in politics, and
they've been stopped by men continuously
and systematically. But what she's
saying is that that actually, the fact
that when you ask women today what
they'd rather do, and there are some
women that say that we would rather stay
at home or some of them that say that
would want to do part-time work and be
with the kids, it shows you that it's
something that they prefer to do. And
obviously, you can see for biological
reasons why that would be the case. Do
you see the the argument here? Yeah. So,
the patriarchy assumes
a lot of it a lot of the definitions of
patriarchy assume that there's been some
suppression by men. A lot of them have
that word in there, subjugation,
suppression.
That men have subdued women and stopped
them from doing what they've they've
inhibited them from doing the things
that they've wanted to do.
But what it fails to understand is that
actually, women have chosen those
things. And imagine if that's women in
the modern world after feminism, imagine
in the pre-modern world when there was
no such thing as feminism. Imagine the
numbers of women that would prefer to be
women uh uh
mothers. I imagine the amount of women
that it would be much higher than that.
So, preference theory can be used as a
way to show that you guys assume that
women
have been stopped by men from doing all
these things, but the fact is
historically and contemporaneously,
they've chosen to have children and have
adaptive roles. Yeah? And bearing in
mind that if we go the past decade,
there was more insecurity and
instability in societies, uh
you know, with you know, wars and stuff.
It's not like you had Tesco around the
corner, police officer, and mechanic
coming in. You they relied heavily on
men more than they did today. So, maybe
they can make that So, if if if in
today's in today's in today's time they
have those privileges, they are still
wanting to go to the workplace, imagine
how would it been back then when they
solely relied on a man. Perfect. So, do
you remember that So, this is a good
point.
Refutation number one was what?
Of patriarchy. Patriarchy assumes that
in many cases that the men having power
women is No, sorry. Do you believe power
relations between men and women indicate
oppression? Yeah. Yeah. And what's our
point?
We said that the child and the mother.
How do you prove that first?
We ask first, how do you how do you
prove that hierarchy equals what?
Oppression. You can't prove it. Yes, you
can't. Yeah. Okay, number two
is
we said
If hierarchy equals oppression, then why
are mothers not oppressing children
throughout history since they have a
power hierarchy over them, yeah? The
third one, and we said some
intersectionalists will bite the bullet.
Yeah. And and they have but bitten the
bullet. The third one, we said what?
We said preference theory, Catherine
Hakim. She makes the argument, she's a
feminist herself, that women are
choosing to go into these vocations.
They are choosing to rear children.
There's a fourth one before questions,
one more and then I'll Not a question.
Maybe this adds on to it. We can see
many examples in power dynamics Yeah.
that the children and women are saved
first.
That's a good point.
>> Can we add that because Yeah, yeah. I
will mention I will mention that. Is
that is that to this point or something
else? There's a fifth one. That's that's
number five. We'll come to that number
five. It's good that you reminded me
actually. Number four before number five
is the intersectionalists
uh
uh refutation. So, feminists themselves
refute patriarchy, okay?
Now, just to remind everyone, there's
let's say three main waves of feminism
for the sake of argument. Yeah, the
fourth wave feminism is there's not
really much to it.
It's not nothing to talk about here.
First wave was what?
Who remembers what the first wave of
feminism was? Equality between the
sexes? In what sense?
Social, economical The first wave. When
was it? What was the what was the main
focus of the first wave of feminism?
No. Voting. Voting. Yeah, voting,
voting, yeah? This was the the
suffragettes and suffragists and all
this kind of stuff.
>> Yeah. Some scholars they say that the
first person who
uh started the first wave was Mary
Wollstonecraft who wrote A Vindication
of the Rights of Women in 1792. Okay, so
they they date it around that time. But
really where the first wave took
prominence was in the enfranchisement
movement where 1792 or 1972? 1792.
Yeah. So, uh
the enfranchisement movement was in the
early 1900s.
Okay, so that you know, that's when
women got the vote in 1914 in this
country and 4 years later in America.
And then in 1924, women over the age of
uh
80 like 18 First it was 35 then it was
18. So, etc. etc. The first wave
movement was was focused on that. We
spoke about how it was a racist
movement. It was anti-black. Elizabeth
Stanton was saying for example that the
black man should How could the black cuz
the black people had the vote before
whites women by the way in America.
Black people had the vote before what?
Women.
And she one of the cases that she was
making, Elizabeth Stanton and others,
was how can this black man, the son of a
slave, that's
a direct quotation, son of a slave, how
can he have this the the the vote before
me?
Before us white women, how? What's her
name? Elizabeth Elizabeth Stanton?
>> Elizabeth Stanton. Stanton? Stanton.
Yeah, it's in the slides. You you'll
find it.
So, how could this black man have the
slave thing before me? So, the first
wave feminist movement, right?
The first wave feminist movement was all
about the vote.
Um
Some call this equity feminism. Some
call this equity feminism.
We don't have as much a problem with
this by the way from the Islamic
perspective as we do with the second and
third waves. The second wave was
Germaine Greer and Betty Friedan. And
now you have abortion, the sexual
liberation, and all these kinds of
things, and equal pay. But then you had
the whole domestic drudgery, and the
mother was being deprecated, and being
in the home was some kind of an
oppression, and all that kind of stuff.
Simone de Beauvoir, The Second Sex, etc.
etc. Then you had third wave feminism,
which is the intersectionalists
approach, okay? The intersectionalists
approach is
where they start to talk about
transgenders, etc. etc. Now, third wave
feminism started in 1984. Most people
say that with Kimberlé Crenshaw
who had this idea of an
intersectionalists approach.
And her point was, and I'll tie this to
the patriarchy, she said the following.
She said that
And actually, she had a refutation of
the of the patriarchy herself, Kimberlé
Crenshaw, yeah? Who's like in a in a way
the the the the main figure that
separated the second and the third wave.
She was a lawyer by profession, I
believe.
And she said that
well, actually, a woman is not just a
woman, is she? She's a woman, she could
be black woman, she could be old or
young, she could be gay or straight.
This is the language they usually use.
These are the four main things they
usually mention, yeah?
Sexual orientation,
age,
um sometimes they bring in disability.
Yeah, but usually those four things,
yeah?
So, they say
we can't just look at oppression and
power dynamics by men versus women.
We have to look at it also including the
black card.
Including uh for example, colonialism.
Including age and disability, etc. etc.,
right?
So, that's why Judith Butler, who was
one of the main figures still alive
today,
and she's one of the main figures of the
third wave uh movement, she refuted
patriarchy. In her book Gender Troubles,
she refuted it and she said, "Well,
that's a binary."
Because it's not just men versus women,
is it? There's there's all kinds of
different A woman is not just a woman,
but she's a black woman.
She's a religious woman. She's a
non-religious Whatever it may be.
There's many different um identifiers. I
wrote a book in refutation of that
called The Fifth Wave Feminism.
But I used her
uh refutation of of patriarchy there as
well.
The point is is that
if you
say that
if you say, "Well, it's not just a
woman, but it's you know, you've got all
these other intersects, yeah? You've got
all these other things." Then the
patriarchy collapses.
Because you can't say that men have been
oppressing women because what what is a
man? What is a woman? We don't even
know. It's a fluid thing.
And number one, number two is that she's
not just a man, but this is a man that's
a white man, a a black woman. I'll give
you just one example from my own that
I've used myself on the streets as well,
and it's been uh successful. That
illustrates this point.
America had the transatlantic slave
trade, right?
So, I want you to imagine a house
with a white man and a white woman.
And they have a black slave, a male
black slave.
Who has more power even according to
them? The white woman or the black
slave?
White woman. The white woman.
So, he's this black slave, if you look
at it very binary in a binary way, he's
meant to be part of the patriarchy
really. He's meant to be colluding with
this other white guy.
But the fact is, it's the white woman
and the and the white man that are
colluding together against a black man.
And you might think it's a trivial
example, but you know, slavery at
transatlantic racist type slavery is one
example. Then you have colonialism.
All these white women are benefiting
from all these brown men.
How can you say that these brown men are
somehow a part of a patriarchy against
the white woman? Do you see the point?
So, when you look at it in a more
complex manner with all the different
intersects,
the intersectionalists approach says
that patriarchy itself kind of
collapses. That's why you'll find a lot
of the second wave feminists, they
really have a gripe with the third wave
ones. There's a fight between them
actually.
The J.K. Rowling, yeah? The one who's
written Harry Potter.
She's always on Twitter like attacking
the transgender. Why do you think she's
doing that?
She's attacking the Why do you think
she's attacking the third wave
feminists?
Why do you think Germaine Greer, who
wrote The Female Eunuch, one of the
biggest figures of the feminist
movement, why do you think that she
attacks
the transgenders? Why? Because she
understands
that the moment you say that gender's
fluid, you destroy the patriarchy.
You're destroying our ideology. You're
you're you're you're you're you're
you're annihilating our religion.
You see the point?
That's why they have infighting.
But we use that infighting to our
advantage.
Cuz it constitutes the fourth refutation
of patriarchy, which is that a woman is
not just a woman, is she? She's many
different things. And how do you know
that it's that men are oppressing women
in the ways that you just described when
you have all these other intersects?
Yeah?
The fifth one is what you mentioned,
Ali.
And this is something which Warren
Farrell, when he wrote And this is We'll
go through a bit of a reading of this.
That he wrote in The Myth of Male Power,
and I think it's a book that everyone
should read. This book is one of the
There's six books I think everyone
should read, yeah, about like feminism.
And this is one of them, The Myth of
Male Power, Warren Farrell, yeah. It's a
classic.
And he says, "Okay, look." He makes a
couple of arguments like the ones that
you're making, right?
One of the arguments is
that he makes.
He says,
"You Men have been forced to do things
in history. For example, conscription.
This is his famous example." And Jordan
Peterson takes his examples and he takes
his arguments and copies them.
He's actually interviewed him once, but
he never gives him credit for the
arguments. It's not his arguments. It's
Warren Farrell's arguments.
He wrote two really good books,
The Myth of Male Power and The Boy
Crisis, both in the reading list of six
books to read about this. You should
read them cover to cover. Excellent
books.
But he makes the point. He says,
"Men have been forced to go into the
army. It's called conscription.
They've been forced.
So, why is that considered to be power?"
He says, "You are defining power in the
wrong way.
Because you're saying power is when a
man has this kind of authority over the
woman. But he's being forced to do
something which is endangering his life
and is endangering his health. Why is
that power?"
And he makes a very interesting
argument. He says this. He says, "If a
woman
is in work, as she shall workplace,
yeah,
and she has four employees that she is a
supervisor of.
So, she she's working somewhere, and
she's got four employees that she's a
supervisor of them, yeah?
And then the managers has to Listen,
you're going to be in charge of 10
people.
Yes, or let's say six, seven people,
whatever it is.
She's going to see that as an expansion
of what? Power.
Cuz her responsibilities have increased.
But he says that if the same woman has
one child and then she has four
children,
it will not be seen the same way. Even
though the influence that she has on
those children is more than the
influence that she has on the employees.
Can you see how their religion crumbles
when you scrutinize it?
You see this Now we're going to come to
the Islamic feminists and all the
pseudo-Islamic feminist nifaq feminists.
But before we get to them,
we have to understand what religion
they're adopting,
consciously or unconsciously.
And before I get to that,
uh I want to mention also
the books that I think we should
everyone should read, okay?
So, the books that you should read
uh if you want to
further your knowledge on this topic.
First book, I mentioned already, The
Myth of Male Power
by Warren Farrell.
And the other one is The Boy Crisis by
him.
Yeah? I've already mentioned some of the
key points relating to the Myth of Male
Power, the arguments that kind of he
makes.
And then he gives like statistics and
statistical arguments of how many men
are in dangerous jobs. You've heard
these arguments before. A lot of the
popular arguments on social media are
from him in that book, okay?
And they're easy arguments. You don't
require an analytical mind for them.
And The Boy Crisis is essentially
showing how boys have been like
under-privileged in the education uh
sector. He has some very interesting
facts about a single parent household
with a man rather than a woman does
better for the child, etc., etc. There's
lots of interesting statistics in that.
Another book which needs to be read
is a book by Christina Hoff Summers.
And this book is called Who Stole
Feminism?
And she does an excellent job in
repudiating feminism.
And she has
>> [snorts]
>> an excellent
she
breakdown
even though she considers herself to be
a feminist. And this is the irony that
she she calls herself an equity feminist
in fact in the first chapter of her
book.
But she goes through she What she does
is she goes through all the statistics,
and she basically says all the things
that people are saying, right, about men
abusing and she goes through some like,
you know, domestic violence, rape
statistics, all these kinds of
statistics, and she says that all the
things that people say about that, let's
examine them. And she scrutinizes
everything. She basically shows that
it's from a sociological perspective, a
lot of it is over-exaggerated or false.
But she has very interesting
terminologies that she uses for what she
calls gender feminists.
For example,
she says that they're chronically
offended.
That these are women that are
chronically offended.
That they have created a gender alliance
model.
Now it's been We've seen that in girl
code and stuff like that. The loyalty
has become a gender loyalty.
And she breaks it down and and and and
does an excellent job in so doing. So,
that's another book that I recommend,
Christina Hoff Summers,
uh
Who Stole Feminism?
Another book which I recommend
is Harrington. She wrote a book
uh called Feminism Against Progress,
okay?
Feminism Against Progress. And this book
is not that long. It's a short book. And
this book
she's refuting feminism.
It's pretty modern book. She even talks
about the red pill movement in there.
One of the only books of its kind that
talk about that in there a little bit.
Her final chapter on motherhood is a
very important one as well.
And she talks about how feminists have
deprecated the how how they deprecated
mothers and stuff like that.
And that's a fact. You know,
a lot of them have attacked the mother
as an oppressive institution like Simone
de Beauvoir. We've We've been through
that before.
Like how Simone de Beauvoir in The
Second Sex, she attacks that.
Mother mothers.
Actually, Simone de Beauvoir and Betty
Friedan, the two
second wave feminists, they had a
conversation one time.
And Betty Friedan,
she was saying, "If a If a woman wants
to stay at home and have and raise the
kids, she should be allowed to do so.
It's her choice."
Cuz she was a liberal feminist.
Simone Simone de Beauvoir, actually, do
you know how she responded? And this is
actually mentioned in this book that
I've just mentioned here. I I read this
in Harrington's book.
That she said that
"No, they should not be given a choice.
Because if they were given a choice,
they would choose to look after their
children.
We can't Basically, we can't trust
women." This is oppression. Yeah, yeah.
So, we've got to force them into work.
Es- Essentially, they don't have a
choice.
So, you'll find really interesting
quotes like this that show you
>> [sighs]
>> how uh the feminist logic crumbles.
Because from one side they want them to
have agency, and from another side they
want to portray them as victims.
So, they're they're the heroes and the
victims at the same time. It doesn't
make any sense. Question? So, that's the
infighting, right? Yeah.
That's the infighting So, the infighting
has happened. But the second wave
feminists are
broadly kind of aligned.
It's more the second and the third wave
feminists that there's been more like,
yeah, more significant infighting.
So, that's one thing.
So, what do we say? We said The Myth of
Male Power.
We said The Boy Crisis.
What else? Against Feminisms by
Christina Hoff Summers. We said
uh
Who Stole Feminism?
Feminism Against Progress. Another
really good one
actually Daniel actually recommended it
to me.
And I read it
in its entirety. It's not that big. It's
a book called
uh A Case Against the Sexual Revolution
by Louise Perry.
Now, it's called A Case Against the
Sexual Revolution. And her name is
Louise Perry, and she's a feminist
herself. Once again, a lot of these are
internal crit- criticisms of feminism.
And uh Louise Perry
basically makes the case
that feminism is in the male interest,
actually.
She makes a very interesting case. She
says feminism is in the male interest.
And she In the first chapter, she talks
about Hugh Hefner. By the way, the fifth
chapter, avoid it, because it's too
graphic. She talks sexual stuff too much
in there.
Chapter five, just avoid this one.
I know that's the first one you're going
to read.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah? But the first first, second, and
third chapters are very important,
actually. And she does like she I mean,
a lot of these women they use like
vulgar terms, by the way, when they when
they're writing there. So, just be
careful. That's like a trigger warning,
whatever, yeah, for the religious
audience. But nevertheless, if someone
is suffering from yani significant
doubts, maybe they should read it. It
doesn't matter. Because go go go to
better than go to hell.
That's a different thing. But, you know,
>> [laughter]
>> Louise Perry,
she is a what you call a reactionary
feminist. She has like more of a
conservative
uh feministic idea. And she basically
says that the And she focuses on like
the hookup culture, dating culture.
She says, "Look, how is this in the How
is this in the interest of women?"
Yeah?
You talk about sexual revolution. You
talk about liberation. It's not
liberation. You're actually doing the
opposite, because comes at a price.
That's one of her quotes. She goes,
"Liberation comes Everything comes at a
price. Liberation comes at a price as
well."
And she says, "Look, if you think Look
at Hugh Hefner as an example. Yeah?
Hugh Hefner,
he had all these kind of like, I don't
know what you call them, escorts or
models or whatever you want to call
them, right?
And then she gives examples of how they
were being abused psychologically and
physically, etc.
And how some of them they commit
suicide, or whatever it may be.
And she says, "How is it the case that
you're saying that this is not in the
male interest?
Feminism is in the male interest. It's
in the interest of the male elites."
She's saying. And she says further that
if you look at hookup culture before she
calls it the disenchantment and
demystification of sex. There's been a
devaluation of sex. Before sex used to
be a big thing.
Sexual intercourse, having a sex.
Used to be a big thing. You have to go
through protocol. You have to go do this
and that and the other, yeah? Before you
have intercourse. Now it's just quickly.
You can get it done. Yeah?
And she's saying that the problem with
that is it reduces the value of sex and
that's in the interest of men because
actually when you reduce the value of
sex
uh then it reduces the value of of the
woman in a sense.
It's easier for the man. Before he had
to have all these commitment things. He
has to pay for this and do that.
Obviously Islam has that in place.
The mahar and the the monthly payments
and all that kind of stuff.
For them the hookup culture there's none
of that. Boyfriend get a magic. None of
that. You don't even need to pay for
anything.
And then you can have intercourse with
the lady. And she even looks very
interestingly. And Harrington also
mentions this in her book. Both of them
love this statistic, but it's an
interesting one. She looks at a sorry to
say and this is a bit of a
crazy thing to say. She looks at the
amount of women that have orgasms in a
casual relationship.
So, you know, men
if you have a casual relationship then
they can have an orgasm in a one night
stand.
She looked at She mentions that
Harrington mentions the same statistic
that only 10% of women orgasm in a
casual relationship.
So, she's basically making the case that
she's not even succeeding she's not even
benefiting sexually.
So, she's not benefiting financially.
She's not benefiting psychologically and
she's not even having a good time.
Do [laughter] you know what I'm trying
to say, akhi?
Because
you can make the argument and I'm sure
there's studies out there which we can
look at that when a woman is in a
long-term relationship with one person
she develops love and stuff like
oxytocin. It's easier for her to feel
relaxed in that context.
Just having intercourse with a stranger
man statistically of as we have seen has
not been a a good thing for her. She
hasn't enjoyed She doesn't enjoy it.
Yeah. She's the one likely to be
>> 90% chance she's not going to
uh
orgasm. And not only that she's more
prone to danger, rape, abuse. Um
what's that black what's that blackmail?
What is it porn um
They use their images to blackmail. What
is it?
There's a word for it.
Are you talking about
revenge porn?
>> Revenge porn. Exactly. Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Uh let me see if there's any other books
that I
should have mentioned. Yeah.
Um
Yeah, one of them I've already
recommended this one to you. I think one
of the important ones. No, we'll we'll
look at We've got it in the slides.
We've got it in the slides.
>> Yeah. There is, but you said ignore it.
We've got it in the slides. We've got it
in the slides. Huh? We've got all the
books in the slides, so you you'll be
fine.
Uh
One of the sixth book, yeah, is called
The Miseducation of Women by James
Tooley. And I've already recommended
that to you
Ali. Yeah.
That's where a lot of the information
but he does a good job in showing the
the same thing. He He shows that how
feminism has not only been in the male
interest
but actually feminism has harmed women.
Yeah.
And that's where I found
uh originally that very seminal uh study
that was done on 100,000 women.
I saw it in his book and then I traced
the bibliography.
The Blancheflower and Oswald study which
is a very important study. It's the
biggest study that's ever been done.
Yeah?
100,000 women in America and England
were asked from the 19th from 1970 to
if they felt cuz obviously after
everything was put into place the
feminist second wave feminist movement
happened in the '60s and the '70s to the
'90s we're we're now seeing if there is
a
increase in their well-being.
And we have found that actually
according to that study
and according to the founding mothers of
feminism second wave feminism like Betty
Friedan and stuff actually their
happiness went down.
And sociologists now have a term for
this. They call it the paradox of female
happiness.
How is it the case that you have more
rights but you have less happiness?
They They consider it to be something of
a paradox.
So,
you can see here with these books what
you'll be able to equip yourself with
is the knowledge of how feminism
benefits men. It's It's first of all
it's been allowed by men.
You can argue
that it's formulated and inspired by men
because as we mentioned the critical
theory a lot of the backdrops and
liberal liberalism listen liberal
feminism is created by men and etc. etc.
And then it's not only been allowed by
men but possibly partially created by
men but it benefits men. Yes. If you
think about it actually they were trying
to fight
the so-called patriarchy
which is not true but in reality they
started an actual patriarchy which is
which is serving men.
Because they created this thing that
they believe that give women more rights
and with studies and examples that you
gave if anything they made a real
that a group of men or whatever you want
to call them that subjugate women and
in the in the disguise of giving them
equality they're not giving them equal
rights. If actually if if anything but
they've created patriarchy in the real
sense. Okay. Perfect.
What we're going to
>> What were the things called
Blancheflower and what? Blancheflower
and Oswald. But it's on the slides.
What we'll do now is we'll have a break,
okay? We're going to have a 5-minute
break.
Uh we're going to stop the camera.
5-minute break. And what we're going to
do is we're going to look at the slides.
Any information that you want to to put
in your notes, put it now because we're
moving on to our next topic. When we
start again we're going to have a couple
of questions, yeah? We're going to
interact with each other a little bit
and then we're going to go through the
next 25 slides. We've done 25 slides
now.
Any Any questions so far?
All right. Let's have a break. 5 minutes
and then we'll come back.
All right. So, any questions regarding
what we've just um
discussed.
Yeah.
I think what's important as well
even though we all know it
is that
alhamdulillah Islam gave rights and
protection to to women. Yeah. So, we
don't need feminism.
Um the argument that feminism you know
protects women and gives them rights and
empowers women
uh of course it's a misguided um
understanding. However, it's it's also
important to promote and to also make
clear the verses in the Quran and the
Hadith especially in these contemporary
times of how Islam empowers and protects
and give rights to women Yes. that is
suitable
and um
that is perfect for uh suitable and
adaptable for the women of today and the
women of the of the past. Well, that's
what we're going to be doing a little
bit of in this segment as well. Great.
Because we're going to be deconstructing
some of the things that Islamic
feminists say Yeah. who are who we refer
to as pseudo-Islamic feminists because
they're not actually following Islam.
Super feminist.
Pseudo-Islamic. Or we call them nifaqi.
For the Gen Z terms we can use that.
Because they're indulging and engaging
in some level of nifaq really. They're
being actually hypocritical to both
>> [snorts]
>> uh Islam and feminism. They So, they're
not even faithful to feminism when you
combine the two because there's
contradictory elements. Yeah. Islamic
feminism in the academy
according to Margot Badran. She's one of
the people who spoke about it. And this
is in the slides as well.
Um
refers to a phenomena
where there's reinterpretive work done,
okay, in order to create gender equality
as she calls it within Islam
or using the Islamic texts.
The main forerunners of feminism in the
academy
uh Islamic feminism
are two main women. One of them is
called Fatima Mernissi, okay? She's
Moroccan actually.
And Amina Wadud, okay? She's also She's
based in California in the University of
Berkeley.
Uh we'll come to what they think. But
this is where the Islamic feminist ideas
came. Right. Um
For me
my categorization of Islamic
pseudo-Islamic feminism is divided into
three. Nifaqi feminists or
pseudo-Islamic feminists.
The third is the most severe. I'm going
to call them type three. Right. Okay?
So, now why this is important We've
We've covered a lot of theory now. We're
going to be moving into a practical
thing, you know.
Like by the end of today we're going to
be talking about strategies of how to
deal with it in the Muslim community.
That's what we're going to be going
towards, yeah?
And but before we do that we need to
understand the scope of the issue.
And to do that I think it's useful for
us to have a categorization. Mhm. Okay?
So, by the way, when I say feminist I'm
not talking about women here. Because
you can be a male feminist.
>> Of course.
Okay? Feminism is a gender neutral
thing. You can be a male feminist.
Type three feminists
for me
are individuals
who
reject either one ayah of the Quran
or a collection of Hadith
because it goes against the feminist
sensibilities.
An example of that is someone like Amina
Wadud.
She looked at chapter 4 verse 34
ar-rijalu qawwamuna ala an-nisa'i bima
faddalallahu ba'dahum ala ba'd.
The ayah that says that men are the
maintainers and protectors or the in
charge of women however you want to
translate.
And she says, "I had a conscientious gap
and I said, 'No.'"
Which means she rejected the ayah.
Which which takes her beyond the pale of
Islam. She's kafir.
Kafir.
She's become murtad actually. She has
become beyond the pale of Islam. You've
left Islam.
Because now you've imposed
your own ideology
on Islam rather than the opposite. The
Quran has moved away from being al-hakim
the judge and is now al-mahkoom the
judged.
And the Quran is not meant to be judged.
If you truly believe that the Quran is
from Allah subhana wa ta'ala
then you don't believe that it's
possible for ethical system to come
outside of the Quran and Sunnah. It's
not possible to believe that. Am shar'a
lahum min ad-dini ma lam ya'dhan
bihillah.
Do have they legislated for them in the
religion what Allah has not given
permission to?
So this is an example of an extreme form
of and we'll come to how to deal and
identify those.
Men and women.
How do we identify in a marriage meeting
in a discussion
in in application, how do we identify
these type threes cuz they're the most
dangerous ones?
Imagine a marriage with somebody like
that. They're raising your children.
They're going to give those ideas to
your children.
That now you're going to
reject the Hadith.
And the reason why they reject the
Hadith is because it's patriarchal.
And we've already refuted patriarchy in
what followed with our refutations of
it.
But because you've adopted that
ideology, you've rejected the Hadith.
And why have you rejected the Hadith
because there's a Hadith that says you
have to obey your husband.
Although the ayah itself chapter 4 verse
34 says fa in at'anakum falatabghu
alayhinna sabeela. If they obey you then
don't don't have any cause of action
against them. Which shows you what? That
women should obey. The wife should obey
the husband. Is mentioned in the Quran.
So they reject the Hadith because it
talks about obedience but the word
obedience they don't realize relating to
the husband is mentioned in the Quran.
So if they were to be consistent they
would reject the Quran.
And frankly, the Quran has more severe
rulings from a feminist perspective than
the Hadith
in many of these things. Polygamy, the
mirath, all of that is in the Quran
actually. Qawamah, all of that is in the
Quran actually.
So if you are so
offended by what you found in the Hadith
about whatever it is Hadith you did not
like
then
the Quran has similar content frankly.
It has similar content and ahkam.
But you have disbelieved in the Quran.
But you're pretending to be a Muslim
for cultural
reasons.
For cultural reasons and you're too
cowardly and ignoble and dishonorable
to announce your kufr and your ridda.
Actually, the apostates are better than
you. Because at least they have the
courage to explain to the world that
they don't believe anymore.
They have a more honorable position,
especially in the West. There's nothing
People don't get When was the last time
somebody in the West got killed because
they were apostated? I have not heard
the story.
And these people should show themselves
and reveal their cards and tell us what
they really believe.
This type three
severe types of
nifaq feminists.
Pseudo-Islamic feminists. Now type two
is a a dangerous one. We know type three
is extreme. I don't think that many
people inshallah ta'ala we don't have
any studies on this in the Muslim
community are type three. Inshallah
ta'ala men and women I don't think is
that many.
Type two I think there's going to be
more than we expect.
And type two is a person who will not
reject
they will not reject the Quran or the
Hadith
and they wouldn't dare to do so because
they know the implications of that. But
what they will say is there's been a
patriarchal and they'll use this term
there has been a patriarchal gatekeeping
of knowledge by Muslim men to Muslim
women
such that
men have disallowed women from being
scholars and they have subdued their
rights and they'll use patriarchal
they'll use patriarchal argumentations
which we've already refuted in part A,
yeah?
In order to show there's been oppression
between men and women throughout time.
That's one sign of a type two feminist.
Another sign of a type two feminist is
that she will look at one of the ahkam
which basically give or have a different
hukm for a man to a woman.
And they will say this is only specific
to the time of the prophet. So you will
say I want to do polygamy or
I believe in polygamy. They'll say no
but and you'll say the prophet did it.
They'll say well that's him, who are
you? That was his time where there was
deaths going on and war going on but
it's not for you.
But what is for you is the provision.
Somehow that's aam and this one is khas.
That one is specific but that one is
general. When it comes to your monthly
payment
huh?
You that's a general ruling, yeah? No
messing around with that.
No messing around with the money. Tax
collector.
But when it comes to the polygamy, now
that one is specific to the time and the
place and the prophet and the sahaba the
companions.
And what usul al-fiqh are they using to
reach that conclusion? Which
jurisprudential method are they using to
that? None because none such
jurisprudential method exists.
Yes?
Isn't the argument here that the
spending on the woman is from her rights
of marriage but
a man practicing polygamy isn't
necessarily
I mean it's his right
>> Yeah, they wouldn't make the argument
like that. We're not saying whether an
individual person should or shouldn't.
We're saying that they'll say the hukm
in general was meant for that time and
that place not for now. The hukm of
polygamy in general was meant for that
time and that place not for that You
someone can advise somebody to give do
polygamy or not do polygamy that's a
different story. Whether he has the
funds the money or whatever, yeah?
But what I'm saying is that a mark of a
type two pseudo-Islamic feminist or
nifaq feminist is that they will specify
all the laws that relate to gender
disparity. They'll specify it to the
time of the prophet and the sahaba. They
will say that it's not applicable to our
times. And there is no jurisprudential
reason for that. There's no
consistent mutlaq usul fiqh that they
can use to make that point. You see the
point here?
>> Of course.
Now once again, we said that it could be
a man or a woman that's a feminist. And
a man can be a feminist type two as
well. How? He can for his own interest
say well I don't believe in providing a
provision. We've we've changed our time.
The times have changed actually. And you
should go to work. I should go to work
and we should jointly contribute to the
house. That's a feministic statement.
Because you're saying all that that
thing with that ruling was
for that time and that place. So a man
can also exhibit type two feministic
behavior and a woman should see that.
Like in the marriage meetings or so she
should suss that out whether he's like
that or not. Where he believes that
provision now is a joint enterprise of
the man and the woman.
Yeah?
Is that all right?
Yeah. I want to go back to type three
just very briefly.
Um
Uh none of us are mujtahid here but
let's say for example we we exhibit a
type three feminist and who looks like
who has the who's one of the muhajabat
who has the hijab on comes out
vehemently vehemently online rejecting
clear-cut ahadith, right?
Uh and she sounds logically saying or he
sounds logically saying and has and is
actually has intellect, right?
Can the layman you know on social media
or in public be like no sorry this is
kufr you're kafir
>> Of course there are points where the
layman
>> do we have to should we do that do we
have to
>> the person rejects an ayah sariha, it's
easier for the layman to do that.
Because it's Well if that person rejects
a Hadith I wouldn't say the layman
should do that.
If they That's why I said a collection
of Hadith. And that's a very important
distinction.
Because rejecting one Hadith does not
make anybody a kafir. Just to be clear
about that.
>> What about
directly or implicitly insulting the
prophet
when it comes to certain ahadith?
>> Well that that needs to be looked into
as a case by case. But what I'm saying
is
that in terms of rejecting an ayah
sariha, a clear-cut ayah sariha like
what I mean I will do so I don't believe
in this ayah. I had I said no to the
ayah.
Essentially, there's there's not much
room for excuse
And the reason why it's important for
the layman sometimes to just take the
plunge and say that you're a kafir
because imagine if you're in a
relationship and the person has done it
to death ridda has become an apostate
then your marriage is actually null and
void.
Because a a nikah is null and void if
you're with a man who says stuff like
that and you're a woman then the
marriage you're committing zina with him
if you continue with him. Your marriage
is null and void. So there's ahkam that
are connected to it. You can't pray
behind the person. You can't eat from
them
There's ahkam that are connected to this
thing. So this is actually there's a
benefit in knowing that this person is a
kafir. And I think the students of
knowledge of certain area should
identify these people and basically say
this is too much and you're a kafir.
Yeah and
make takfir of these individuals and
there's a maslaha in that.
>> And just quick disclaimer we're not
trying to look for to make takfir
anyways.
>> not making takfir but you've asked the
question about when to do it when the
layman can do it. Like for example if
somebody bought the Quran he's not
majnun he's not sakran he's not
anything. He doesn't have an immense
impediment. And he brings the Quran and
he starts ripping up and eating it like
David would.
Do we need a mujtahid to say that this
man's a kafir?
>> No. Okay so there are some things that
the layman
it's well known that the layman can
decide this person's a kafir. Okay.
>> If someone comes and says I'm a mulhid I
am a kafir I've left Islam. Do you need
a mujtahid for that? You don't need a
mujtahid for that.
So it depends on the severity of the
crime but I'm saying if someone says I
don't believe in this ayah he knows it's
in the Quran or she knows it's in the
Quran but he's saying I don't believe in
it. Then the person's a kafir.
And we need to know about that because
then we don't want to welcome them into
our community in this way.
And there's there's a there's a maslaha
in identifying the person as a kafir in
that way. Okay? The second type though
is is more sticky because I want to
I want to create a refutation for them.
And we're going to spend a little bit of
time refuting the claim that men have
been the gatekeepers of knowledge, okay?
And that they have done all these kinds
of things and all the specific claim
etc. etc. right?
The first thing is
let's take this argument to its logical
extreme.
If they're using patriarchy theory in
order to say that men have been
the gatekeepers of knowledge and that
they're therefore untrustworthy and
they've been oppressing women, etc.
Then why do you accept the Quran when
the asaneed of the Quran itself are
based on men?
The Quran itself
the majority of the chains of narration
of the Quran is based on men. If you
cannot trust the knowledge
of the Quran
of the men, yeah, because they are in
they're doing things in their own
interest, then you have to reject the
Quran, actually.
So, the entailment of what you believe
that there's been a mass conspiracy of
Muslim men scholars, all of which have
conspired to try and gatekeep and stop
women for their own privilege and
purpose and for their own interest and
subjugate women,
then why do you believe chains of
narration
which are comprised sometimes
exclusively
by men?
Some ayahs in the Quran there's not one
woman in the chain of narration. You
would have to reject those particular
ayahs.
So, that's the first argument.
So, number one, the asaneed would break
down.
Number two, al-ijma would break down.
Because the ijma is based on a lot of it
is on on men.
So, how can you have ijma, which is one
of the masadir of sharia,
which is consensus, one of the sources
of sharia, how can you have ijma without
men?
Therefore, you've you've taken out two
things. You've taken out the deen.
You've taken out the Quran, you've taken
out the sunnah, and you've taken out
ijma. You've You've left with nothing.
So, by by placing such suspicion on men
that they're doing things in their own
self-interest and they cannot act
differently because it's biologically
predetermined, as we said, critical race
theorists and critical theorists
believe that you're wrong on the basis
of who you are, not on the basis of what
argument you make, which is, by the way,
the genetic fallacy.
They If If a man is making the argument
about women, then you're wrong because
you are in a position of power, you
shouldn't make. If you're a white man
making the argument about black person,
you're wrong because a white man is in a
position of power and the black person
That's the genetic fallacy.
That's the genetic fallacy. We've
already shown that it's not necessarily
the case that if somebody says something
that they're wrong because of it. So,
they've taken this idea from critical
theory and they've taken this idea from
the Frankfurt School. And now they've
imposed it on the hadith and the Quran
and Islam. And what they're left with is
nothing because actually Islam was
preserved by men.
And their theory is wrong, actually.
Because what they're saying is that
women
huh, have been
uh not allowed to engage in scholarship.
And that's a false statement, actually.
In fact,
I propose the following and I would like
to be disproven.
I believe that there has been more
Muslim alimas
in Islamic studies throughout history
than there has been is the Western
alimas in all of the fields.
And you might think that that's an
over-exaggeration. It really is not.
How is it the case, if it's the case,
that men are trying to gatekeep women,
huh, and stop them, that you have women
who are alim and who have come to the
same conclusion as the men and sometimes
a more severe and harsh conclusion
from a ficky perspective about polygamy,
about all those gender issues. Was she
duped? Was she naive? Was she a fool?
So, now you have to say that these women
are all duped. There's a collective
naivety of women all over the world that
they were duped. They were duped to be
mothers, they were duped to be wives,
they were duped to be
uh to believe in the rulings that they
would do and men were controlling even
their thoughts.
So,
women therefore have no agency.
If that's what you believe, that women
en masse, and by the way, imagine this
claim. It's a mass conspiracy, mass
collusion claim.
Because Islamic empire has spanned over
so many different civilization and
geographical regions.
It's been the Mali empire in Africa, as
an example. Many African empires that
are Muslim.
North African empires that are Muslim.
Spanish
empire that is Muslim.
It went from Spain to China, yeah?
The Turks, this, that, the Persians.
All of those men, the Turks and the
Persians and the Africans and the
Ottomans and the Europeans and all of
them, the Arabs, all of them together,
they conspired
and they colluded to stop women from
learning
together.
They came together and they they they
they made this plan
that we have to stop the women from
learning because if we make them learn,
they will go and get their rights and
they will know their rights and they
will attack us with their rights.
That's a racist essentialist claim,
claim, actually. All of these men from
all of these races, they have to get it
wrong.
So, by being a feminist, you have to be
essentialist. You have to essentialize
all the men together. Bunch them all
together. All of these different men
from all of these different
civilizations.
Akram Nadwi wrote a book called
al-Muhaddithat,
which is a book
He was actually my teacher for 2 years.
Uh
I studied under him for 2 years. Not 5
years.
2 or 3 years.
Not 5 years. 2 or 3 years.
And
he brought this up. He wrote this
compendious volume, 8,000
hadith scholars.
Okay. All of them are women, 8,000
mentioned in the book.
Now, you don't have to mention all the
names.
But I've got a couple of names in here
if you want to see them.
Okay. Obviously, we know about the
sahabiyat. Everyone knows about Aisha.
Everyone knows about Umm Salamah.
Everyone knows about
Hafsa. Everyone knows about these names.
Khadijah. Everyone knows about these
ones. And they all say, "You keep
mentioning the mothers of the believers.
Who else have you got?" As if we don't
have anyone else. As if we don't have
any any names
of women in different fields.
In the in different poets.
They come by that in the time of
once once upon a time. Yeah. woman
radi allahu anhu was a woman.
>> Yeah. So, you had different things like
so Karima al-Marwaziyyah, for example.
She is a woman who I think modern-day
Uzbekistan.
She was in charge of uh
basically hadith transmission of
Bukhari. She was one of the main
transmitters of Bukhari.
Without her, we would not have Bukhari
today.
We would not have the transmission of
Bukhari today.
Men would go to her to seek knowledge
from her.
And this is the 15th century.
Early Islam.
She's She's transmitting the most
authoritative and authentic book of
hadith in Islam. And she's one of the
main transmitters.
I've actually written a list in the
slides
of different women
in different fields.
And you can see with that,
in addition to the
sahabah, etc.
Yes, you can see. Look, here we go.
Zaynab bint Kamal, yeah? Damascus.
Once again, a huge hadith uh scholar.
Aisha bint Abd al-Hadi, yeah?
There's so many of them.
And some of them are like muftis. Some
of them are taught the judges, etc.,
etc., yeah?
They came to the same conclusion as the
men did.
>> [clears throat]
>> Now,
that's type two feminism and how to
refute it. How do we refute What is type
two feminism? Whether somebody says that
there was a mass collusion theory and a
patriarchy that was taking in the
gatekeeping of knowledge.
If someone comes and says that stuff,
uses the terms patriarchy and misogyny
in that context, then they're type two.
They're severely affected by the
feminist framework.
And they're refuted because in number
one, the the patriarchy is refuted, so
they're refuted by extension. Because
not every single type of authority, as
we've mentioned, is oppressive and
there's no way of proving that, anyway.
The second way that you can refute them
is by stating huh,
that actually the mass collusion theory
is an essentialist theory and doesn't
hold any weight. Number three, that you
had so many Muslim female scholars, as
we mentioned uh we mentioned a secondary
source,
which 8,000 names inside of it.
Number four,
what else did we say?
Who remembers?
Hm?
Uh
From what you said before, that they
claim the type two, they claim women
have not been allowed to be involved in
Islamic scholarship.
Yes.
>> And And they have been involved in it.
Yeah. Yeah, and they have been involved
in it. So, so in other words, in order
to say that they came to the same
conclusion as men,
and they did so because they were duped
by them, it's to claim that they were
naive.
You can't have it both ways. Either the
woman had agency or they were naive.
They were naive, they were being duped
by men, they were being forced by men,
they were being brainwashed by men.
Is that your vision? That's a
You could argue misogynistic idea of
women. That women have been naive
throughout the centuries, for 1,400
years of Islamic history, for for 5,000
years of human civilization, they're all
naive, they're all dumb and being duped
by all the men hypnotizing them,
hypnotizing them in all of civilization,
yeah, and collectively.
So, this is the type two.
The type two may also say that these
rulings are specific and she has no way
of ascertaining that these rulings like
polygamy or inheritance are specific.
She's just saying that because she wants
to fit in with it. And this is a pathway
very, very close to type three. Like the
next thing you're going to say is kufri
stuff. Khalas, finished. And a lot of
the type two people
are using and attacking the scholars
because they actually attack what they
say.
And what they say is based on Quran and
sunnah and because they know
that the Quran and sunnah says certain
things they don't agree with and that if
they say it
like that, they will make the the kufur
will happen on them, takfir will happen
on them, they just use the scholars as a
scapegoat.
A lot of them are actually they have
hidden nifaq inside of them and they are
not
they are not convinced of the veracity
of Islam.
The proposition that Prophet Muhammad
came in the cave and that the angel came
to him and that he said and that was
from Allah and that was the angel said
that stuff. They don't they don't
believe 100%. They they wouldn't put
their life on it. They're hedging their
bets. A lot of them are hedging their
Maybe Islam is true, maybe feminism is
true, maybe Islam is not true and and
their unconscious mind potentially
and remember this could be a man or
woman, right? Their unconscious mind
is playing games with them. They don't
they're trying to hedge their bets
whether Islam is true I'll I'll do this
much so that if Islam is true that I'm
not kafir. Pascal's wager but then if it
is like they're on the precipice of it.
They're on the cusp of it. Yeah, someone
can convince them to be type three
easily. They're very susceptible to
become type three. Type twos are
dangerous.
They're in a position you don't want
them as a wife. If you're a religious
person who believes in Quran or Sunnah
and you don't want them as a husband.
Why would you want someone who says that
stuff as a wife or raising your kids?
Raising them with a shubuhat.
Obviously if you've got kids with them
already that's a different discussion.
I mean you know that's a different as we
said you know the nuclear family is more
powerful and this information about that
and we don't want to cause any divorces
today.
But you know if you're if you don't have
any kids with them then
it's better
to remove them from your life.
These two type twos 100% whether you're
a man or a woman it's better to get them
out of your life. After you give them
the dawa
it's better to remove them from your
life.
Because these people if they consist
on if they persist on this trajectory
it's a a slippery slope to type three
and kuf and nifaq
full fledged. We don't want that.
And as I'll come to when we talk about
strategies
the thing is like men have a power here.
Not patriarchal power like they would
say but we do have a power of like we
can decide like the free market
economics. We can decide who to marry
and who not to marry no one's going to
force us.
Who we want to be with and who we want
to be with.
If they don't fit the criterion
okay of believing Quran and Sunnah in a
puritanical way a proper scripturalist
way
a proper traditional way
a proper true Muslim way yeah? If they
don't do that why would we want them in
our lives? Why?
It
could be better to marry a Christian.
Because a Christian you can give her
dawa and she'll be pure.
Give her a probation period in your mind
six months I'll give her a dawa for six
months.
Yeah? And then if she becomes a Muslim
she can in all of them are kafir.
Giving dawa to a type two
and giving dawa to a Christian is the
same.
It could be the same.
Your chances of success are similar.
Quite frankly.
Yes Allah.
Wanted to say that
the
the original default for woman
is that she is she's weak. Yeah, Allah
created them weaker than than men. Yes.
And Allah says in the Quran in Sunnah
and
they said
that this is men being weak for women so
we're both weak for each other.
But Allah created the woman that to the
husband.
By default she obeys her husband.
>> Exactly. It's more natural for her to to
obey her husband. It's more natural for
her to be influenced by her husband or
father.
But having said that we also as men have
a manner.
And and we also have more power as you
mentioned earlier that I am in the Quran
that shows that Allah made this society
this structure.
The Prophet he said fear Allah
Fear Allah
in regards to to your women your sisters
your daughters your spouses.
I'm glad you hesitated because you're
creating a good balance actually.
>> [laughter]
>> I realize that now.
Yes.
>> You
took them with a manner from Allah to
Allah.
And then Allah
also tells us to deal with our wives
with manner.
To to live with them with with
compassion with goodness with with with
mercy.
And I think part of the problem is men.
Of course. What what do I mean? The
reason why women are not women today is
because men are not men today. That's
true. The Prophet
he said
all of you are
all of you
are
responsible
And
all of you are shepherds I e leaders
with responsibility and all of you are
responsible for their flock and he then
started with the men.
The man is the the head of the
household. Likewise the first people to
be asked are those with authority. So so
men are in authority over
the household.
Meaning
any type of volume
against wives and and or daughters and
so on there is an Islamic account
accountability for that but because we
don't live in an Islamic state
there there are men that do get away
with
with volume. And I think women like I
said in my first point are weak.
And there are many organizations and
movements and ideologies with billions
of funding targeting in particular our
Muslim women.
Yes. And perhaps from our families and
people that we know are being affected
by this. Absolutely. So I think that one
of the ways to to approach it is from a
mercy mercy perspective
and a protective perspective.
We are the protectors over them to to
protect them from from these ideologies
and to
to educate them. To educate them but
also to make sure that we also give them
the rights that Islam gave them
so they're not in need That's true. I
think that's a very good point. I'm glad
that you said that.
Some of these sisters today
that are like listening to feminist
speakers and so on. I think many of them
are naive and many of them are innocent.
[snorts]
Okay. And you know what I think is a is
an important distinction that I should
have made.
This is a very important distinction.
Let's say you've got a type two that
we've just spoken about someone who has
whatever yeah?
If you've got a type two and they're
humble
meaning if they if you've got a type two
man
husband or wife but they're humble so
they they have these shubuhat but they
want them to be um
kind of undone okay? They want to get
rid of them themselves. It's different
to having someone who's doing
he's a die to the bid'ah.
This guy is a mubtadi okay? But he's a
die to the bid'ah as well okay? So this
person now is calling to the bid'ah that
they have.
Do you know what I mean? So this
individual
he or she is convinced that there's a
patriarchal oppression and stuff like
that so and they're not taking it.
They're not having it. This is their
view and they're trying to convince
others of that. That's a different
person to a person who says I've got
these doubts. I'm going to go to
Lighthouse mentoring service. I'm going
to go here and there I'm going to try
and remove this expansion from my heart.
With the one who has arrogance
sometimes the best thing is
to leave them because you don't want
that to be especially before the
kids get into the equation.
To them for them to infect your children
with this. You know?
So that's if it's not if the person has
hope then you give them dawa. So a lot
of it's to do with the disposition I
think of the individual as well.
I'm in I'm in I'm in complete agreement
with
with regards to what he said about how
there's
billions of funding that has been given
to these ideologies to target our Muslim
women and I feel like a lot of them are
vulnerable. Yeah. And they may go
through certain situations and they
don't know where to look they don't know
who to blame so they fall susceptible to
all of these isms schisms ideologies
etc. etc.
Um but at the same time he he he kind of
jumped the gun a little bit because you
only spoke about type two and type three
I suspect when you speak about type one
this this this kind of
would suit them would suit them more
rather than the type two and type three.
This is my categorization a lot of it is
you know
you can decide to do what you want with
whoever you want. It's just you know.
But what I'm saying is
personally I think that if let me tell
you the the the reason behind it right?
Adam Smith referred to
in economics something called the
invisible hand of the economy okay?
The invisible hand is that prices are
set based on what demand and supply.
Every most people want to be in a
companionship relationship yeah? Most
people men and women and this is not
specific to women as I mentioned in the
beginning this is gender neutral man or
woman want to be in a partnership.
If we raise the spiritual standard
and make it a non-negotiable
for that if you want to be in a marriage
with a religious person you're a
religious person watching this you want
to be in a marriage with a religious
person
then you have to exhibit religious
beliefs.
It's only fair.
I believe in Quran and Sunnah. I believe
that this is what came from Allah and
the and the messenger.
You should believe in the same thing.
You should not be influenced by these
ideologies.
If we raise the standards on that
then it will be diminished by
Smithsonian logic.
Like by demand and supply market
economics logic if people are just more
cutthroat about this men and women that
if you're going to talk talk to me about
patriarchy and internalized misogyny and
all of these kinds of things that you're
you're getting from the white woman
because you're you're you're you are
trapped under a colonial boot of the
white woman. You've taken yourself out
of the fake patriarchy of men and you've
put yourself under the real patriarchy
of the white woman
who's made all these ideas. It wasn't a
black woman that made it.
It wasn't feminism was not started by
black women like bell hooks in Audrey
Lord in the 1980s that came out in the
third wave of movement.
It was started by white racist women.
And you're jumping under that. If you
want to do that, that's fine, but I'm
not interested in this.
I would rather have a relationship with
somebody who believes in what I believe.
A tayyibun?
Tayyibun. Yeah.
The the tayyib people should be together
and the khabith people should be
together.
If this is the case with sexual
immorality,
then bab awla is the case with aqidah.
Wallahi, someone who is khabith but it
does repentance is better than someone
who's khabith in his aqidah and he can
continues to be khabith.
Munharif.
Deviant.
Mubtadi'.
Maybe fasiq, maybe kafir even and is on
the way to being kafir.
This person we want to remove. So, type
three and type two are kind of severe
types to be honest.
You don't want it's like COVID. You
don't want them around you.
They'll infect you and they'll infect
their kids as well.
Type ones are the ones with shubuhat.
They want to know what's the hikmah of
ta'addud.
the mirath being different, the
inheritance being different.
And they come to the man or the woman
they say, "Look,
I believe in Allah alhamdulillah. I
don't have any but I just have a few few
things." This person should be given
mercy in my opinion.
And this person should be allowed to
to discover themselves in their own time
etc.
The type ones are the severe, the mild
types.
This is okay.
Because this person is still exhibiting
a great deal of humility.
This person is still solid on the basics
of Islam.
So, you have type three which is the
most severe, they're kafir or munafiq or
on the way to being that.
Type two, once again, they're not kafir
or munafiq but they're on their way
and they're using foreign ideologies to
do hukm of the Quran and Sunnah and
Islamic sharia.
And the type one is the one with
shubuhat which we we're not going to
we're not going to judge in the same
manner.
This categorization will help us
understand. Now, I think what's really
important and I I thought about this
before I present it
is
to mention what doesn't make you a
feminist.
Okay?
And the way I have actually come to this
conclusion
is based on because there's a lot of
accusation of who's a feminist.
Men throw this term around a lot as
well, especially, yeah? On women that
exhibit certain traits and whatever.
It's not always correct
to to classify somebody as a feminist
for certain things. Now, what are those
certain things? Surely, one of those
things should be the things that the
mothers of the believers did.
For example, Aisha, we all know the
story of her breaking the plate because
she was jealous.
The prophet said she was jealous. So,
yeah, a woman that's jealous, are you
you're a feminist now? No.
If she becomes jealous, even to the
point of Ummu Salamah, when the prophet
was about to propose to her, what did
she say?
She says, "I don't I'm a jealous woman."
Essentially, that's the beginning of
what she said. I said yeah, I can't
handle it. Essentially, what she's
saying, I can't handle this polygamy.
I'm a jealous woman.
And then the prophet said, "I'll make
dua for you." And he made dua for her
and then they became married.
But look at the initial stage. She's
saying, "I can't handle polygamy not
because I disagree with the ruling
but because I'm a jealous woman and my
emotions may not be able to handle it."
So, a woman rejecting
polygamy for herself is not a feminist.
Or someone who's saying that I don't
want it for myself is not that's not a
feminist.
She's just saying I don't want it for
myself. You know, I in the beginning she
was she had to be convinced a little bit
or whatever.
But the point is that doesn't that
doesn't insinuate that's a feminist.
>> [laughter]
>> Likewise, a woman who says I want to
work is not a feminist.
Especially if she has the qualifications
for it. Like for medical student for a
long time she's been doing medicine. She
you know, I want to practice a little
bit before
before she don't why is she a feminist
because she wants to do that? No.
That doesn't make her a feminist.
Because her aqidah might be different.
She just wants to do it because it she
sees it as a waste of her potential and
time that she was done all these studies
and she wants to work a little bit. It
doesn't make her a feminist. Obviously,
it's a discussion she has to have before
the nikah takes place, before the
authority is handed over.
But nevertheless, just because a woman
wants to work
or because she exhibits masculine
traits. For example, some women in the
battlefield of the prophet used to
fight. Used to fight. Many of them
actually. There's so many of them.
I've put it in the slides.
They used to fight physical. Ummu
Sulaym. Huh? Ummu Sulaym.
Exactly. Exactly.
So,
these are women who used to fight. So,
somebody who has these kind of traits
and that's not a feminist.
You have women out there that are very
strong.
Strong-minded women. You have
extroverted women. An extroverted woman
is not a feminist.
She likes to talk loudly. But something
she she needs to work on but she's not a
feminist because of it.
So, there are
the word feminist is thrown around fi
ghayri mahall.
In inappropriate ways.
I've put in the slides actually 10
examples of
um
Ummu Salamah, this is another example.
Subhanallah, it's a very good one.
Even look imagine the question that she
asked. She came to the prophet and you
know what she said to him?
She said to him, "Why are women not
mentioned in the Quran the same way as
that men are mentioned?"
You you look at the level of questioning
here.
And I'm only telling you this because
it's like
what's this?
It we would brand that as maybe type one
feminism or shubuhat or what?
This is Ummu Salamah and we've already
mentioned Ummu Salamah before where she
said I can't handle the polygamy.
She said, "Why are women not mentioned
the same way
as men are?"
Now, obviously, when we know this
already in the Arabic language
when Allah mentions the masculine he
includes the feminine.
But just to make sure Allah revealed the
ayah Quran because of her question.
Allah revealed an ayah in the Quran for
that to make sure that women know
that when it comes to spirituality there
is equality in spirituality. In this
regard, you will your deeds will not be
uh
trivialized.
Inna al-muslimina wa al-muslimat wa
al-mu'minina wa al-mu'minat wa
al-qanitina wa al-qanitat etc. etc. The
surely the believing men and the
believing women and the
and the ones who are pious men and the
pious women and the the fasting men and
the fasting women and etc. etc. Men,
women, men, women, men, women. Allah
made sure that you understand that this
religion is not exclusionary of women.
He had to make sure of it.
He revealed the ayah to Ummu Salamah
because just to make sure. But just as a
point of notice here.
Ummu Salamah was not asking
because she was in concerned with
feminist ideology. There was no such
thing as feminist ideology. She was
asking because she wanted to reap
rewards, spiritual rewards. And she
wanted to make sure that the rewards
were going to be granted for her if she
does them.
It's the same as the hadith of that the
woman is you know, she asked men get to
do this and men get to do that. They go
janazah prayers and they do jihad. And
the prophet told her if you're in your
house you do jihad. She's looking for
what? Rewards. It's a different
motivation.
So, just because a woman asked a
question about why the Quran says
certain things
or doesn't say certain things does not
make her a feminist.
She's allowed to ask that and even if
it's gender-based questioning.
She's not a feminist because of it
because if that would make her a
feminist then it would make Ummu Salamah
a feminist. She's a feminist too then.
And feminism didn't even exist.
You see? So, we have to give concession
here.
The reactions of women because of
polygamy.
We can't say that that's feministic.
Ibn Hajar al-Asqalani got married to a
secret wife.
He got married to a secret wife.
His wife is actually his wife is called
Ummu Sulaym.
And she was a scholar of hadith just
like he was.
And
she
uh first of all, why is he hiding it if
it's okay?
Cuz obviously he knew that she'd react
in a certain way. When she had that
secret wife
and she found out about it
Ibn Hajar
yes?
She knew that her he Ibn Hajar wanted
his son that's going to be alim.
And she made dua that his son will never
become alim.
So, she's acting emotionally now. The
first wife? The first wife. And who's
alim by the way. So, she's
she's a alimah woman who's married to
one of the greatest alims of all time in
Islam.
The sahib sharh al-kabir which Fath
al-Bari. Yeah, the big sharh. The most
important sharh. Explanation of Bukhari
in all time.
She's the mother she is the wife of
that.
She is the wife of that guy, Ibn Hajar
al-Asqalani.
And she is reacting in a way
that's erratic to polygamy.
She's emotional.
Oh, she's a feminist. How can she be
just because you doesn't mean you're a
feminist because you're acting in an
emotional manner.
So, so much so that I even looked at
some of the shuruhat
of Nawawi and others when they're
talking about the hadith of the Ummu
Sulaym and the the breaking of the
plate. And he said that she's not even
put it up too much in your mind here.
But she's not even mukallaf for it
because she was acting out of insanity.
Ghayr iradi.
It was actually she was acting so mad
that she wouldn't even cuz she's not in
control of her faculties.
So, yeah, just because a woman's acting
like that is not she's not a feminist
because of that.
And many need to be
appreciate that point. What did you want
to ask? Uh just wanted to say Ummu
Sulaym means bakhoor in Somali.
And um
it's used like in Somali culture
when men are coming home they they tell
their wives put the unsi on basically.
Yes.
So, maybe maybe it came from maybe it
came from there.
Mhm.
And he was Shafi, isn't it? Ibn Hajar.
got
Yeah, and
somebody have accepted the
absolutely. Thank you for you smiling.
Oh, you're broken, right? What are you
from?
Oh, okay. Interesting.
There's other examples like Al-Khansa.
Al-Khansa, we said there's lots of women
that are poets etc. One of them was
Al-Khansa, yeah?
She her brother died then she came out
she make poetry and she was crying and
lamenting
publicly.
That her poetry is some of the best
poetry ever written by an Arab
or ever written by anybody in Arabic
language.
And she was a woman. She was a proper
poet, okay? She was expressing her
emotions etc. in public, okay? And she
was actually a Sahabi.
As an example.
Another example
is Hafsa and Aisha.
In Surat At-Tahrim,
Allah reprimands the Prophet Muhammad
for what he made haram.
Allah is Ghafur Ar-Raheem.
That why do you try and make halal what
Allah made haram? He's not saying that
it's it's the halal of the kufar or
whatever. Why do you make it? To try and
please your wives.
Why wait Nabi and the Hadith and the
ayah continues that basically the most
famous story is the story of the honey
and there was a conspiracy between the
two wives. This is how far it went.
Aisha conspired with Hafsa to say
something to the Prophet to make him
feel uncomfortable.
Now, if something like that happened
between somebody with two you say this
is obviously girl code that you're
doing.
This is obviously because it's female
loyalty and it's obviously because of
this and it's all because of feminism.
As I say, this is just behavior that
they exhibited. It wasn't something
connected to any of the things that
we've just mentioned.
So, you see just because a woman acts
emotionally to something, it does not
mean that she is a feminist or even
influenced by feminism. And if that was
the case then we would be having to
accuse the mothers of the believers of
this thing.
You see?
But having said that so this is a
important disclaimer
and there's many many examples of this,
you know? This is an important
disclaimer.
But
that doesn't mean that somebody when
they start speaking in a Aqeedah way,
I believe that men have oppressed and
gatekept and we have to decenter
from the male authority.
Decentering from the men.
This is what they call it. This is
actually a radical feminist
terminology.
Decentering.
It's a radical feminist ideology.
It came from radical feminism and that
actually it then start being used in the
third wave quite often.
And it means to try and do things
without the approval of the man. How can
you be a Muslim and decenter when you
have to do that for the man? When you
have to obey the man and you have to
accept his authority.
Then you are a liar about one of your
claims.
Cuz if you don't want the approval of
men,
it means
that you have rejected the tenant of
Islam or that you don't understand it.
And they will use terms like
internalized misogyny or she's a pick
me.
Why is she a pick me? Because she is
saying things
which are in line with the male
interest.
If a woman comes out and says something
like, you know, oh you know,
a man has a right to marry four wives.
Oh, you're a pick me, aren't you? Trying
to get married, aren't you? Trying to be
a second wife to someone, right?
So, they start bullying.
They start bullying each other on these
points.
This is clearly feministically inspired.
Clearly. They're using jargon of the
feminists
and we have to be very clear about that.
All right, we'll have a a 5-minute
break. We're nearly finished by the way,
guys. We're nearly nearly finished. 5
minutes and then we'll have the same
thing as before and then we'll come back
and and discuss, okay?
We covered a couple of things now. We
covered number one.
We covered
what feminism is. We covered what
patriarchy is and we covered the
refutations of patriarchy. We covered
some of the main books that are
reputational of feminism
and then we moved on to some of the
arguments against feminism as a whole,
how it's in the best interest of men
according to some like Louis Perry and
in some aspects
and who talked about the sexual
revolution and other people economic
arguments etc. We spoke about how it's
not in the interest of women, yes? And
then we moved on to what's referred to
as Islamic feminism, what we dubbed as
pseudo-Islamic feminism
or nifaq feminism as your your nice
nifaqi. Nifaqi. Nifaqi for sure.
Yeah.
And then we spoke about the three types.
The type three which is the most severe,
type two which is the second most severe
and then type one which has shubuhat
etc.
And then
we spoke about some of the claims of the
type twos which we refuted refuted and
repudiated in turn. We And what were
some of the claims quickly?
That they believe that there's been
something of knowledge.
What do the type twos believe, yes?
Yeah, gatekeeping of knowledge
suppressed by women, excellent. And what
do what some of the responses for that?
Yeah, why is that?
Cuz every chain of narration that goes
back to the Quran itself.
Yeah, so the whole deen would be
debunked if you have suspicion of men as
a whole because then you can't you
cannot trust that Hadith.
Yeah, women have been duped, they're
naive.
Yes, that women they they implicitly
claiming that women have been Muslim
women throughout the centuries have been
duped. And that they're claiming that
that they're a bunch of idiots for
thousands and thousands of years.
Beautiful. And so what else would we
what did we say about this bit?
Female scholarship and what did
Well, 8,000 I mentioned I had in that
book only. That
Akram Nadwi's book of Muhaddithat and
that's only in Hadith by the way. That's
not talking about fiqh and all that as
well. Go on. Can we ask them say is
there any historical documents or any
testimonies from any woman in centuries
like in the 7th, 8th, 9th, 10th claiming
that they are under patriarchy?
That's a beautiful that's an excellent
question.
Yes,
>> [clears throat]
>> the question that's a beautiful
question. Why is it for all these years
that no Muslim woman was able to come to
the conclusion the correct conclusion of
the white woman? And also don't just
Muslim woman is there anything from the
non-Muslim woman in society in history
we have documents we find that say look
we're under the patriarchy and heavily
been oppressed.
There's nothing like that. Excellent.
No, there was not there was not because
if there was they would have mentioned
it. And what they usually mention is the
vindication as we saw Mary
Wollstonecraft's
first major book of first wave feminism
that was in 1792.
And say you are basically saying that
because you deemed to be under a
patriarchy that throughout history every
woman was. And do you have any documents
to prove it? Absolutely. Now, that's
these are good arguments. These are good
arguments, yeah?
An opinion an opinion that I reached a
humble contribution that I'd like to run
by you and see what the everybody thinks
about it is also if they were to use
that theory that because you know men
narrations and everything that the
theory that you brought that that can't
be the case because of different empires
at different places at different times
all being
simultaneously agreed on one thing.
Statistically that is nearer to zero
than zero because even in Islamic
sciences as you know,
you know, which is I think in my opinion
the most in-depth science ever.
The highest level of Hadith is mutawatir
which is built on the fact that
different places at different times and
different narrations
that say the exact same thing.
Therefore, this can't be fake. So, just
to add to that so you're debunking the
whole mutawatir thing as well by saying
exactly
mutawatir asaneed everything.
[clears throat]
So,
excellent. Beautiful, okay?
The last part of it is just to mention
the following.
We need to bring spirituality into this
a little bit and also psychology.
Any question, yeah?
Just a suggestion. I think it'd be nice
to like when you have talk about
spirituality I think it'd be nice to end
it with you know the verse of Surat
At-Tawbah verse 71 that the
believers both men and women are
guardians of one another they encourage
good and forbid evil establish prayer
and I appreciate that's that's a good
thing to bring up, yeah.
>> [clears throat]
>> Mashallah.
Well, you know what I'm saying, right?
Yeah.
Look, it's very good but when I say
about spirituality and psychology these
two things are really connected, yeah?
Cuz psychologists would use terms
like resentment
and so would spiritualists like
for example what I told you that book
that I
recommended to you in the beginning
Christina Hoff Sommers and she wrote
that book
I don't remember the name of the book.
Who stole feminism? Yeah. Yeah.
Very good book. I recommend it. And in
chapter four of that book she talks
about some psychological reasons and she
says the real reason why women have this
a lot of women have these issues and she
she talks about women, right? She says
the real reason why a lot of them have
it is because they resent men.
They actually resent them,
okay? Some people have gone through some
traumatic experience in their life or
they feel like the world is against them
and they have she calls it righteous
indignation,
okay? So, she feels like the world is
against her or these men are against her
and stuff like that. Now, from our
perspective as Muslims clearly that's a
maradhul qalb. That is a disease of the
heart.
And so a lot of these issues you you've
got to treat them intellectually
but you've also got to treat them
spiritually
because if someone has is haaqid
maghlul someone has ghill and hiqd
resentment and contempt hatred karahiya
towards another believer
that's something that they as a Muslim
from a spiritual perspective must
realize that they have to expunge from
their hearts. If they don't realize
that, then they are
exhibiting Luciferian traits.
These are the and women.
The devil, Lucifer, was very angry with
Adam because he was jealous of him.
And that's where we lead you to
arrogance and rejection of the dean.
So, somebody who's concerned with their
own spirituality
must do this of the club.
And that's here of it.
That's why they
famous to hobby who was probably
probably probably agenda.
He says that I, you know, before I go to
bed every night
I make sure that I don't have any I
don't have any I don't have any
resentment towards any of the believers.
And there's a and the Quran about the
judge people in Medina.
We are made we have to make dua sort of
the hash up that we make dua in chapter
59.
That oh Allah
let us not have resentment in our heart
for the believers.
So, if it's true that
somebody is inspired or is attracted to
his ideologies cuz they've been through
some traumatic experience because
they've witnessed something with their
father, the mother, whatever it may be
and they have this hatred and misandry
or whatever it may be. And then it
becomes more attractive for them these
ideologies, then they have to work on
themselves, yeah.
You know one thing you know you talked
about the second wave of feminism of
sexual liberation.
Um you can say that for example you see
a lot of um like a lot of these you know
far women western ideology they follow
they get they they they really get um
used and abused by men. Yeah. Uh there's
one that actually committed suicide. She
she actually said that her failed
relationships. That's very interesting
because I think it relates back to that
book, you know, because
women have let men like you said
given them it's it's in it's in a man's
benefit. Yeah. Now when it's in a man's
benefit then that means a man doesn't
need to go through obstacles to treat
her right. Mhm. And therefore it
backfires on them. They get resentment
and hatred based on what they've
created. Absolutely.
>> You've created this system. Yes. And
based on this system of sexual
liberation you are allowing the men to
come and get what they want and go. Yes.
>> Then you are resentful because of that.
Yes. You've created this cycle. So, if
anything you should attack yourself
because you've created this patriarchy
that you deem to be. That's why in my
like conversation that I was having when
I speak to a lot of women Mhm. um the
reason why I like they're all into this
topic as well is because a lot of women
come to Islam because they do not
understand how they have been sexually
objectified, you know, book that I
always read which Muhammad Hijab says
the strongest book I've read in my life
the beauty sick. I mean actually another
one called girls on edge. There's
another one called the beauty myth by
the way. You should read Really? Yeah,
there's one of girls on edge as well,
yeah. So, it's it's if you speak to them
they like they really it's like a wake
up call to the women like when you say
to them listen Islam has these protocols
you can see the the the the eyes growing
in the sense of really I was like yes
this this I'm like you're the prize in
Islam. I I like and I always mention
this about like my wife when I got
married had to speak to her father and
get permission mother the the the the
the the the the yeah. So, so, so you can
see some they're actually starving for
Islam especially women and that's why a
lot of them come to Islam.
Um and it's it's very very interesting
to find out because when you look at it
they've caused their own misery and then
they blame it on the patriarch.
>> Actually, do you know on this point I
was just looking at notes whilst you
were doing it cuz I I I wrote notes when
I read that book of the sexual
revolution, yeah.
And she says something interesting. A
part of the reason why she says that um
men are benefiting more
from that from basically this whole
hookup culture in liberal feminism. She
says that this is Luciferian that book a
case against the sexual revolution. She
says that men are more social sexual
socially sexual. She calls it social
sexuality. Social sexuality
is the idea that you want more than one
partner. Yes. Yeah.
And woman is more hypergamous. We know
what that means, right? So, she will
marry up as uh
Jane Austen mentions, yeah.
And pride and prejudice marrying up is a
term that was I think initiated from
her. But anyway, nevertheless
so, social sexuality versus hypergamy,
yeah. And she she makes an interesting
point and so does Harrington in her
book. I think she even quotes Louise
Perry actually.
She's impressed with that.
And she says that essentially
a man biologically can inseminate so
many different women at the same time.
Whereas a woman can't do that so she has
to be more selective. So, she gives kind
of like a biological explanation for it.
Jordan Peterson talks about Yeah, and
they I think they get it from these and
to be fair she mentions David Buss. I
think this is the the common trend
because Jordan Peterson has had him on
his podcast multiple times. Louise Perry
mentions David Buss multiple times in
the book as well. So, that's the common
trend. She quotes him a couple of times.
Uh nevertheless
um this idea
of um someone who's more socially sexual
will benefit more from a hookup culture
from dating and non non-commitment than
someone who's hypergamous because they
they enjoy a variety and they get more
from it. Yeah.
Um
So, yeah so this
she and then she makes an argument
against BDSM by the way.
And she's like I mean this is in chapter
five. You're not going to read it cuz
it's I told you don't read it. But she
was
I already read it for you guys.
You know, she she she she says that this
is these are men who basically wanting
to abuse the woman by finding it that
and an avenue to do it.
Um
what else did she say that I found
interesting? I think the motherhood
thing yeah. So, she as well as
Harrington have this whole thing about
motherhood and how motherhood's been
deprecated by the feminists and has been
reduced. And she mentions something very
interesting. She she says that
only 3% according to her Louise Perry
she says 3% okay of papers done in
gender studies are about mothers.
So, feminists essentially they don't
care about mothers' interests.
Yeah, we already know that okay like
Simone de Beauvoir considered motherhood
to be in the second section oppressive.
We already know that the second wave
feminist movement was like
um
vehemently against motherhood and
domesticity and stuff like that. But now
you have this reality as well which is
that the motherhood thing is and read
chapter five of Harrington's book. It's
a whole book on
uh motherhood as well. So, okay we've
discussed the spiritual thing which we
just said now that a lot of the reason
as Harrington mentions is because of
righteous indignation is because of
resentment is because of hatred is
because of hatred
A lot of them refer to as penis envy,
yeah. They you're just upset about the
fact that you know this guy is doing
things like Allah says in Quran well let
it be my father Allah be by the Allah
but
little angel in a silly moment I can't
win in the same moment I can't win in
the same
what's a moment of fun day.
Do not wish what the other one has. For
a man is a portion of what he has earned
and for a woman is a portion of what she
has earned. And ask Allah from his
bounty.
So,
there are things that a woman can do
that a man can't. And you know why it's
seen as
ridiculous to mention it is because
these feminists have deprecated the
institution of motherhood. So, if we say
okay well a mother okay
can give birth
and she can be attached to her child and
she can give breastfeed the child and
she can do all those things and she has
an intimate relationship with the child.
She that could even be considered to be
a sexist remark because it's kind of
like biological determinism.
Which really one of the only things that
woman can
excel over a man
in in a way that yeah if you look at all
the parameters there's no other almost
nothing else that she can excel over a
man in that way.
Having kids and giving breast milk and
all that stuff.
But it's the one thing they've
deprecated the most which is ironic
because it's meant to be about female
empowerment.
If I want to empower myself I talk about
the the most unique aspect of myself.
Feminism has stripped the woman of the
most unique aspect of herself which is
the ability to be a mother. Yeah. And to
connect with the child. Yeah. It's
ironic. Yeah, and then that's where the
woman releases most oxytocin. Exactly.
Abundant like when she's breast
feeding and the connection is it's it's
crazy bro. There was this I came across
Instagram post where the woman is
basically
she pumps up
breast milk into these patch things to
feed the babies. Bro, it's it's it's
miraculous. She she shows the the milk
in different colors and she says that
for example when he's when when she was
away from the baby
obviously the body thought that the
baby's being dehydrated. So, what it
produced was more water substance in the
milk. It changes color bro. It's like
the connection they have is crazy bro.
The milk like if the baby's ill the milk
changes Yes. and it just shows you like
that this is where they are the most
happy and they've literally robbed them
off that and dropped them dropped them
to such a low level. Um and I think I'm
not sure with the definition of
feminism that you mentioned which I
usually use in the doubt table is like
the greatest form of inequality is to
treat unequal things equally. Mhm. And
if you look at it what does feminism
say?
>> what Aristotle said actually. Well don't
take this me it's me.
Maybe he thought like me this is quite
common. It's a like thing should be
treated like for like and Yes, because
the definition of feminism is equality.
But we're saying the greatest inequality
is to treat unequal things equally.
>> Mhm. Well, that's very interesting.
Well, the great greatest form of
inequity is to treat unequal things
equally. Yeah, that that would make some
sense. But for me I'll be honest I had
this long conversation with a lot of
them Louise Perry about this.
And there's an issue with framing it
like that.
Um the issue is that you could argue
that that's um
the naturalistic fallacy. Okay, so like
me playing devil's advocate someone
could say it's a naturalistic fallacy
because you're saying that just because
something is a certain way it ought to
be a certain way. What what do you mean
by that? It long story is that I don't
want to go into it. It's a technical
thing. But I would put it the other way.
I would if you ask it as a question you
avoid that. So, if you ask it and you
say
can you prove to me that unequal things
should be treated equally rather than
saying unequal things should be treated
equally.
Mhm. Uh should be treated unequally. If
you make the claim prescriptively then
they'll say that well you're you're
falling into naturalistic fallacy is
what fallacy because just because
something is
that way. Whereas
if you if you ask it as a question then
you avoid it. It's it's a fine
distinction. But you know from a from an
argumentative perspective that's the way
that you could circumvent it.
I want to ask you guys a question now
since we've we've pretty much covered
all the main content. We've got three
types of
pseudo Islamic feminists or lucky
feminists.
It could be a man it could be a woman.
Let's start with the most severe type.
We've already said, you know,
get rid of them, right?
Type two and type one, I want to get you
guys' strategies of how to deal with it.
I I'll give you one of mine to start us
off and tell me what I know at least I'm
not an advocate of this as well, yeah?
I think that
there should be something called or I'm
not going to give it a name actually,
but something like a probationary
marriage, okay?
Now, I'm not saying that you put a time
and that is mut'ah. We say I'm not
saying it's mut'ah. Mut'ah is just just
to be clear.
>> No, just don't have kids for 2 years.
No,
mut'ah is like when you say to somebody,
oh, you know, this is when the marriage
will end. I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about you go into a
marriage,
you don't have kids for some time. Yeah,
you don't have kids for 6 months or 1
year or 2 years, whatever it is you
decide depending on your judgment. But
at least 6 months or a year, at least.
Like, you know, you look at it, yeah?
>> Or 2 years, 2 years. And you analyze,
you think it's 2 years? Yeah, that's
could be could be right.
You analyze the situation and you see if
they exhibit this person exhibits
whatever they exhibit. And if they
exhibit it, I would go further and say
you should prove If you're a man, you
could just What's the point of having
this in your hands if you're Why would
you introduce a child into this?
It's like, for example, if you married a
Christian woman who's 'afifah for the
sake of argument because there's a
question of
are you allowed to marry a unchaste
Christian woman? And the majority of
them say no, some of them say it's
allowed like the Hanafi's and it's a
minority opinion in the Hanbali madhhab.
Wa qala ba'd al-ashab
al-Mirdawi says that it's possible that
you can, but that's only a minority
opinion in the Hanbali madhhab.
It's hard to find a chaste Christian
woman nowadays anyway, but the problem
is this.
If you if you marry a for example
Christian woman, right? And you give her
da'wah
and then she does not respond to your
da'wah. You're not going to have kids
with her, are you?
Like, if you if you marry a Christian
woman and you give her da'wah for 6
months and then she becomes a Muslim,
she starts wearing whatever she's
wearing and becomes a proper Muslim and
stuff like that, you could you can
decide, okay, this person has reformed,
I'm going to have kids with them.
And can you get come into a marriage
with that in your mind? Not I'm not
saying it's as a written contract. And
the answer is yes, you can and that's
what the al-jumhur say. Actually, it's
what everyone says.
As Ibn Qudamah mentions, he says
uh illal-Awza'i, except for al-Awza'i,
he says it's mut'ah. But apart from
al-Awza'i, essentially everyone says you
can go in with this kind of an intention
where you're trying to see whether this
person is suitable for you or not. And
sometimes it's better to cut.
Yeah, you know, like now I think there's
a there's a movement against divorce,
yeah? Divorce can sometimes be a rahmah
and sometimes can be a solution.
Okay? Uh it can be a solution to
something problematic, akhi. If you're
going into a marriage and this person,
okay, has these traits, why are you
staying with this person? All your life
they're going to raise your kids with
this and that because you can't handle 3
months of heartbreak.
It's going to You're you're going to
recover, you know.
You are going to recover. You you'll get
hurt a little bit, but you have to have
standards. You know what I'm trying to
say? Same thing with a woman, but to a
lesser extent cuz she doesn't have
divorce in her hand. But if she has some
guy that's a third type three feminist,
then she might she might need to have it
because he's apostate anyway.
So,
>> [laughter]
>> anyway,
this is just my one of my ideas. As I
said, I think the market will
calibrates itself if people have strict
criterion. We sieve away all of this
mubtada' and these fusaaq and munharif
because at the end of the day that's
what they are. A lot of them are
munharif.
They are deviants. These people are the
real deviants.
These are deviants who bring in foreign
ideology into Islam. They should be
labeled as such and they should be left
and they have to now repent before they
come in. But anyway, maybe I'm being a
bit too harsh. Any other strategies and
ideas? Go ahead, someone. Um
On that, no, uh not one of the
strategies I think would be really good
to incorporate, especially in the
contemporary times we live in, right?
With all the issues on TikTok with uh
with the Muslim sisters being slightly
affected and even though even the ones a
lot of them they actually don't call
themselves feminists, but they just kind
of relate to some of the posts and some
of these sub stories cuz they are actual
actual realities that actually exist. I
think we should have more Muslim women
da'iyats, right? Who are educated
alimat, muftiyat and can educate them
and be like a source of inspiration and
role models instead of having, you know,
like hijabi barbies or
only fan models, you know what I mean?
That's a good point. Anything else? Any
other exactly, yes.
So,
I've recently noticed that obviously the
feminist movement is continuing to grow
obviously, but I've also noticed like
being online and stuff that the
anti-feminist movement from women
who are waking up getting educated about
the matter
are sort of waking up and saying, "No,
this is not what we want." And
speaking against it.
>> Yes. So,
from what I've sort of gathered is that
it's the education that's making them
wake up and realize cuz from what we see
from these Muslim sisters, a lot of them
they don't realize what they're doing is
going against the word of Allah.
>> Yeah.
So, how do we as a society
educate them? Cuz obviously we can we
can we can go and read ourselves, but
how do we educate the masses about this
matter? I think that like you said,
education is very good and like we need
to make the teaching feminism or
deconstructing feminism as part of the
'aqidah package that you as a
conservative Muslim parent teach your
kids when they're 10 years old.
From like 10, 11, 12, you need to start
telling them this is deviance. Because
if they if you don't do it at that This
is the time where you have them. If you
don't do it at that time, then when they
get to 18, it's game over.
Yeah.
Don't know. Check on her.
Jazakallahu khair. Um
I disagree with your strategy. Yes.
Um
>> It's good to have difference of opinion.
Yeah.
But I still love you for the sake of
Allah.
>> That's fine. What do you think you
should do?
>> Well, I think in terms of investigating
if this is a suitable wife or not, if
she has these views and opinions, then
that should happen pre-nikah. Okay?
>> Yeah. Um it's a it's a sacred contract.
>> Mhm. So, when we're doing a a business
contract, for example, uh with a
potential business partner, I'm going to
um ask about the person. I'm going to
get some references. I'm going to speak
to people who dealt with them.
Um and I'm go I'm going to make a very
good decision
uh based on all this information. And
likewise with with marriage, maybe even
more so. And it's halal to backbite in
Islam in this occasion to ask about a
woman or a business partner uh in order
to to find out about the person. So, I
don't think
uh we should get married to anyone.
>> think that's a good point. I I I think
before the before the nikah is Yeah.
Maybe we should formulate some
questions. Okay, so what to ask to see
if they're a type one or a type two or a
type three. Like, for example, a
question could be, "What do you think of
the patriarchy?" That's just a simple
question. What do you think of this
term? If she says, "Well, I think
there's some there's some truth into it,
blah blah blah blah." That's already red
flags. If you if you ask her, for
example, um "What do you think of the
fact that male scholarship have
dominated history?" And she says, "Well,
what do you think of these ahkam? Are
they specific or are they general?" She
says they're general, but they I don't
like it for myself. That's different,
you see?
>> think there are ways to to find out what
you know, the type of person
Ask them what do they What do they think
about Ali Dawah Muhammad Hijab. If they
if they don't like him, then that's a
red flag. The manhaj. Yeah,
you test them with
>> It's actually It's actually funny
>> [laughter]
>> It's actually funny because there's one
brother he works for us at Salaf. He was
getting to know a sister for marriage.
He He goes He goes I told her uh He goes
I told her um
I work with Ali Dawah. She She started
She laughed She laughed. She thought he
was joking. He goes, "No, wallahi." He
goes She goes, "Really?" He goes,
"Wallahi, but she blocked me so fast."
You know, I said to myself, "This is
This is a blessing from Allah." You
know, um you know what we can do is Can
we spy on them? Uh in the sense where
can we go into their like if if a
brother's getting to know like someone
for marriage, can he go to their account
and see what kind of comments and posts
she's liking? And she can do the same
with him. No, that's fine. No, she can
do both ways. No, this is a personal
both people. Can they do it?
Cuz you This is someone you're going to
spend the rest of your life with. Yeah,
of course. I'm talking about this. When
you like there's
businesses they uh I'm on the cover.
they do reference checks.
They get companies to do reference
checks. Okay, guys, let me speak cuz
he's just Yeah. They go on social media
posts and get an idea of the person.
That's that's absolutely fine. As for
like a strategy, and by the way, the the
Prophet when the young person came to
him and said, "Ya Rasulullah, allow me
to commit fahsha, zina."
The Prophet didn't respond to him with
Quran and Sunnah or evidence. He spoke
to him in a logical way. He said, "Would
you accept that for your sister? Would
you accept that for your mother? Would
you accept that for your daughter?"
Yeah. So, likewise, we won't accept that
for our own daughters, sisters,
uh the women in our family. As a
strategy, my my my my idea is I think
two things, fulfillment and flexibility.
Your point in terms of can women work?
Yes, obviously with Islamic guidelines.
And I think in today's age,
we should allow women
to either work, volunteer, or do
something that brings them fulfillment.
Otherwise, they might fall into
depression, they might burn out, and the
person that they will blame is their
father, brothers, or their their
husbands. As we said, there sometimes
it's not even a choice. Sometimes the
the payments are so much that both of
them have to work. Yeah, so they need
some sort of flexibility because
cuz of her just mental well-being.
Because if if she believes that I'm just
a housewife cooking and cleaning, and
that's not fulfillment for every type of
woman.
Uh if she's if she's doing like a da'wah
project or if she's involved with a
sisters' initiative or if she's working
in a halal job
because making money is fulfillment.
It's not for the sake of income and
that's her money. She doesn't have to
contribute unless she wants to. Uh then
I I say there's maslahah in that. Okay?
>> Yeah, I mean, it's what it what it could
be is like a psychological thing. So,
what you're doing is you're trying to
you notice that she has resentment,
okay? And you're helping her reduce that
resentment. No, but that's I don't I
don't agree with that. It's just based
on case studies cuz a lot of the
practicing brothers, especially from the
Salafi community, in the '90s and 2000s,
there was a famous fatwa from Saudi
Arabia that women can't go to university
and women can't drive. Okay? And these
sisters now now they are they used to be
niqabis, now they're publicly without
niqab and and even doing some doubtful
things. But that's because of
um
That's the the based on case studies
lack of fulfillment. They felt
depressed, they felt burned out.
Uh they felt like they were they were
restricted. So, I think Islam does not
forbid
um
a woman working within Islamic
guidelines if it's going to bring her
some fulfillment, then I think there's a
maslaha for the husband to to allow
that. Like the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
>> but then yeah, but then okay, so we all
Wasallam
agree that No, no, he can he can allow
it. But but the question is if he
decides not to.
Because now the authority becomes in his
hand, right?
>> the question's not even that. Why is it
that they are programmed to not find
motherhood where studies show that they
are the most happiest has not been
fulfilled. Yeah, absolutely. What So,
where is that stemming from? That's
stemming from feminism. That's stemming
from that I don't feel valued and I
don't feel I'm doing something the most
important thing. And it's not centric,
it's not Allah centric, it's not taqwa
centric. Because if it was, you're
talking about the next generation of
children. So much so that they are
thinking by making extra cash or income,
whatever it is, you've got children,
kids. That's the next generation of the
ummah. They might be the next generation
of ummah that's going to fight the
Dajjal with Isa Alayhis
Salaam's army.
We are they are more concerned of
um uh holidays or you know, upgrading
this and that. So, the thing is what
what is making them feel that motherhood
is not a a a a achievement.
>> But Ali, here's the here's the thing. I
want to try to to to
do harmonize between your to harmonize
between your opinions, right?
I think that
Look, as we mentioned, some of the
Sahabiyat had different proclivities.
So, some of them like to fight in the in
the in the war. Okay? Some of them
really loved to do charity. Okay? The
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam told
us that one of his the one who dies
first is the one who's
atwalu hayatan. Actually, hadith says
the longest arm, which means it's a it's
like a majaz for she gives charity a
lot. So, she goes out in the community
to give charity, etc., right?
Or see
>> Some of them like Like Aisha loved and
she would give fatwa, etc., right?
Um it's just proclivity. Now, it's not
necessarily the case that because a
woman has a particular proclivity that
she's influenced by feminism. Okay?
However,
it can be if she has an ideological
belief and she states it. So, she says,
"Why is it that men get to do X and
women don't get to do Y?" It's a fine
line, that one. Is is that one that was
a fine line, yeah. even if she does have
that view,
I think that's where tarbiyah comes.
Yeah. You are a product of your
environment. We have to be waqi'in.
Yeah.
When someone asked Sheikh Muhammad
Al-Masri,
"What is the hukm of those who don't
pray?"
And he knew that there are people who
are listening to his dars there who
don't pray. The person asking that
question is hinting.
He said hukmuhu to take his hand and
teach him how to pray.
He didn't want to do takfir. Our sisters
are being poisoned today. It's it's a
it's a fact that feminism is a poisonous
ideology and many of our sisters,
including people
>> the Prophet even people in our family,
probably. The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said there will be a time
where you have to lock women in chains
cuz you can't control them.
20, 30 years ago,
uh there's more influence. Today, we
don't have actually freedom or or power
over women. If someone la qadar Allah
has a has a sister
who has a boyfriend, what can you do?
If someone has a has a cousin or if
someone Many brothers who I'm saying
these are case studies.
A lot of their wives have asked for
divorce and they took off hijab and and
and and they're doing all sorts of
things. So, from a maslaha perspective,
uh Ali Radiyallahu Anhu, he said, "La
tukhatibun nas bima la yafqahun." Do not
speak to people in matters that they
don't understand. This is going to be a
gradual thing. We need to do tarbiyah.
And you know, let's
let's Shaytan awan li akhik as well. You
know the hadith
hadith of Prophet Don't let the Don't
let the devil be
friend of your brother. of removing this
from from our from our society. And
there's lots of [clears throat]
tarbiyah, starting with our own
daughters, inshallah Ta'ala. Yeah.
Uh and fulfillment will protect them
from from from
>> Yeah, so I think there's a fine line. As
just just to put my two cents in, I
think that you're absolutely right. Um
if if a woman has a strong urge to do
something, whether it's volunteering at
a charity or something like that, it
might not be wise for the man to to try
and inhibit that because then she will
have that resentment and the resentment
can become feminism. Yes. You know, so
we don't want to we don't As we just
mentioned,
a lot of feminists become feminists
because they're being inhibited.
And it comes from some kind of
That one's a a tricky one. I wouldn't
say she's definitely feminist. It
depends on how she states her belief. If
she says, "Why do men get to do X and we
are only mothers and we are only" and
she's trivializing her own role as a
mother.
That one's a little bit more
sophisticated. If she's a very
intelligent woman and she's great at
science and she goes into medicine.
Like I said before, I gave that example.
Like she might want to practice a bit
because why do six years and then not be
able to to do anything with it? That
stuff is sensical, like
The Jews and the Christians
will be the doctors of our sisters and
Yeah, but she has to marry a guy that
basically understands that and accepts
that and is flexible enough for that,
whatever, you know? And not every man
will be like that.
>> Do Do you accept the type one, type two,
type three categorization that
Muhammad Hijab gave?
No, I don't I don't agree with
I'm talking about how to deal with it.
Yeah, yeah. So,
Yeah, yeah.
then it needs it needs tarbiyah. It
needs Accepted. Accepted. Accepted. But
do you accept his
type one, type two, type three
categorization?
Yeah? Yeah, it's fantastic. Yeah, so so
if if if that's the case, then of course
I I I think what you're saying works for
type one. But type two, type three,
especially type three, is munafiqin
Not even just don't marry,
excommunicate.
Mhm. Because the two things that destroy
the ummah
today,
especially,
is the dunya, hubbud dunya,
and women. Even non-Muslims, this is now
written in books
about how to be a successful
businessman. One of the pitfalls of of
being a successful business is women.
Mhm. Trump was bankrupt because of
women. Well, look at him now, the
absolute But they'll say Look at the
absolute fall, exactly. But they'll say
that what you just said is misogynistic.
That's that's where we're at with these
kind of things. Like you need to be very
careful what you say. So, this is
But I think No, no, but that but that's
but that's not my point is that though.
Because I feel like we are totally
ridding women of accountability. Like I
genuinely see that and and that's so
dangerous because we're just like, "Oh,
men" and I agree, by the way. I blame
men and I've talked about this a lot
because we are the ones that Allah's
given us
that thing and men are not meant to
lead, you know?
Which I've told you many situations uh
you know, university talks have been
canceled because a few sisters are
crying about something that's not basic.
So, men are to blame eventually, but
what we're doing is we're ridding women
of accountability. And already they
sadly, yes,
they don't have it. It just gets worse
when we just blame men all the time
because they should take accountability.
Because how are you going to rule over a
woman that doesn't want to be led? We
need to wrap up because of the the
memory card, yeah.
And the battery. One last
one last contribution. Hassam, you want
to say something first? And you don't
want to say anything? No. Okay, go
ahead.
I'll go after him. Yeah, go. Whoever you
you go first.
I [clears throat] think when when you're
talking about as well
sort of solutions and things, how we can
go, you know, you were saying vetting
the sisters or vetting them and things
like that before marriage, etc. Brothers
as well.
And uh and I think I've mentioned this
before to you and to a few people about
social media, obviously.
And
we need to sort of put an agreement in
that into marriages that we
you're you're saying about, you know,
looking at sisters' profiles and seeing
what kind of things they're feeling. I
see him going further than that that
both the brother and the sister should
be like, you know,
remove themselves from social media.
Remove that element as much as possible.
Try and roll back because
and you know, this is cuz this is this
is causing a lot of problems these days.
This is one of the few things
>> Absolutely. A lot of it is coming from
social media. And and you know, Sheikh
Hamza was saying about, you know,
letting forgiving them fulfillment to go
out work.
Because one of the problems is if
they're at home, then what's the what's
the thing going to be doing? He's on
social media. And come across these
posts
doing scrolling like everyone does. And
then this week come across these corrupt
videos and things like that that that
you know, corrupt men and women.
Absolutely. So, I think that's a key
>> there's like self-regulation. The
strategies for someone for themselves
and the strategies of what how we deal
with each other as well. Sure.
Yeah. Keep them busy, good. Jazakallahu
Khairan, everyone. It was a fantastic
session. We've covered so much ground. I
think he wanted to say something. Do you
want to say something? Yeah, yeah. Yeah,
go ahead, please.
Do we have time? Yeah, go ahead. Uh
really really quickly. So, brother
brother Saheeb said something beautiful.
He said that you know, on TikTok,
usually the feminism and and Instagram
and a lot of things happen on social
media these days and there's a lot of
pushback coming from women themselves
these days against the ideology of
feminism. Like, "Why wouldn't I want a
man to take care of me? I want to be a
stay-at-home mom. This is my dream." and
whatever and and so on and so forth. So,
you that could be linked to the
invisible hand that you were talking
about earlier being that because of the
geopolitical state of the ummah in
recent times at its head, Gaza, I feel
like there's been a global spiritual
awakening, especially to the Muslims,
which is now seeped on to basically
the Muslim woman. And that also links to
the point that Sheikh Omar Hajaj was
talking about earlier
when he said that one of the possible
reasons could be that men are not being
men.
So, therefore, women are not being
women. So, it's tipping the balance,
which is also the invisible
>> think it's a good it's a good point
you're making. I I think the Gaza point
is actually poignant because
the fact of the matter is this is that
we've found throughout history that
colonial administrations have used
equality logic in order to subjugate
entire populations. Like when the
British Empire went into Egypt,
actually,
um they used gender equality parameters
in order to subjugate the population,
even though some of the things that they
were calling for were not even
implemented in Britain at the time.
So,
uh that's one thing. The other thing is
that we see it now with Gaza and so on
and so forth. We see how much Western
feminists actually even care about the
Gaza or they care about these things.
It's they Western feminism and colonial
feminism has primarily been concerned
with the rights of the white woman.
And when Muslim women who are not white
realize that, then it becomes even more
powerful for them, you know? It's like
that historically and it's like that
contemporaneously. We said that before
in the colonial empires,
they wanted to civilize civilizing
missions. Look what these guys did. They
were using
they were they were using colonial
feminism as a
uh as a pretext to go into Afghanistan.
Yeah. And they're talking about women's
rights and stuff and you got Trump is is
is a is a he's doing what he's doing and
he's you see if you if you look at the
Epstein files and what he's done, it's
absolutely shocking. You know, the
sexual stuff
with the 12-year-old and all these kind
of things that he's bite the penis and
all this. I don't know if you saw it.
Crazy.
And he's the one going to talk about
Afghanistan and talking about wars and
talking about these and these are the
same people that ones in Epstein files.
That's about emancipating Afghanistan
and they're killing the women in
Afghanistan. How many women have they
killed?
And they're using feministic jargon as a
means a pretext to kill the women. So,
surely a woman who's has solidarity with
her other Muslim woman will look at that
and say, "Well, actually, the feminists
have not been on our side." It's a good
place to end this.
>> just one strategic thing to use is you
mentioned it as well that Muslim
feminist women are 10 years behind. We
really need to capitalize on these
heads of these feminists non-kuffar
to awaken the Muslim woman and say,
"Listen, you are" if you think about it,
they're 10 years behind, bro. No, even
older than that. These these women are
coming and they're they're insulting
feminism. Some sisters are still
thinking that's the way. So, it's very
important to capitalize on these women
who are the forefront like who was the
one that was promoting about not getting
married and she got married herself?
Uh [snorts] for example,
um
The one that What's her mother's name?
Yeah. But she didn't get married, but
she was promoting like, you know, lack
of housework and stuff and she was
cleaning up the house for example or
John Paul Sartre her boyfriend and
stuff.
Yeah, absolutely. So, I mean, look, you
make excellent points. Everyone's made
really good points and contributions.
I'm happy that there was like diversity
of opinions here because sometimes I can
get a little bit passionate with these
kinds of topics. So, it's good that we
had like diversity of views and
opinions.
And I'm happy that we spoke about the
strategies and made it applicable as
well. Like what would we actually do and
how do we change society?
And with that, we will conclude and I'm
sure you guys have uh have benefited. Uh
there's no question here you have. Uh
this is cutting-edge information. And uh
great minds in this room, mashallah.
Influenced influential minds. We've also
got Al Idhwa here as well.
>> [laughter]
>> And the other people.
Hopefully, you've benefited. Was salaam
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.